this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today an
executive session may be held on any
Bill referred to the committee please
note that there's no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to the meeting
however in accordance with the emerging
emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through Zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
electronic calendar on the general
forward
notice for this meeting complies with
house rules and RSA 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 or email
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by a roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance when each member states
they're present please also State
whether there's anyone in the room with
you meeting which is required under the
s
representative Bailey president
representative fellows
present Home Alone
representative
I am present home and my wife is in the
house as well
representative goalie
here
at my home and my wife is in the other
room
we will wait for representative Judy
I'm here at home with with my husband
representative one Zara
I'm here home my family is in other
rooms
representative O'Brien
I am present I'm hearing on at home in
Nashua and I've got grandchildren all
representative Pearson
present State House Roy
yeah representative representative Santo
nastasso
I'm here in Paris
representative Schmidt
I'm president in Portsmouth New
Hampshire at the home of a friend who's
not presently in the room
representative shuitt
I am present at my home in Pembroke
alone
representative Schultz at my residence
in Concord and my husband Gene Taylor
will be in and out of the room
the clerk is present uh representative
yakovich
thank you
I'm sorry
um representative reckis I'm president
in the committee room and representative
McGuire is not here but expected
momentarily
that's correct
sorry
so are we all present except for
representative uh Representatives uh
Judy has not answered the role as this
if he should anybody notices his arrival
please let me know
he he
just so you know and I'm going to resend
him the link so he should be here in a
minute or so
okay
thank you
a few seconds to see representative Judy
like to open the public hearing on HB
forward
on the Belt you can introduce them yet
Tony you want to introduce that bill and
I'm sure everyone signed up to test but
let me just look at the attendees to
Aaron but she's not is she on the Belt
she's the lead
representative Aaron and recognize her
at agency
Mr chairman your sound quality is quite
[Music]
foreign
yeah I'm here do you hear me I'm here
okay now go ahead all right hang on one
minute uh let me get this on here
I can't see you
we can't hear me yes we hear you okay
all right well
um so this is representative Judy Aaron
I'm uh representing Sullivan seven
representing Acworth Goshen Langdon
and
um so I want to present this bill to you
um
uh adds a public notification element to
a statute that has been on the book
since 1953.
the statute itself was last recodified
in 1985.
and to anyone's knowledge has never been
used the current statue allows for
departments and agencies within the
state of New Hampshire
and with approval by the governor and
the executive Council to perform weather
modification experiments alone or in
conjunction with the federal government
and or other states there's no current
mechanism other than the usual public
notice of executive Council meetings and
agenda to let the public know what type
of weather experimentation or
modification might be proposed or
planned
I'd like to briefly go through the
history of this statute because we need
to know the background of how it got to
be the current statute came to be as
part of a
um to be as a result of sweeping changes
of recodification of agricultural
statutes back in 1985.
it was part of hb25 which was about 300
pages long
and the first 293 Pages dealt with title
XL while the last handful of pages
included RSA 12--f the whole thing
passed and so this statute was
recodified and moved to its current
place in our law it used to be chapter
432 colon 1.
prior to the 1985 recodification this
weather modification experimentation
legislation was first introduced into
the legislature's house resources
Recreation and development committee as
far back as 1953 as hb412 it was
considered in 1953 with regard to
project cirrus cloud seeding for rain
making in times of drought and that
possible experiments would be done at
the Mount Washington Observatory
at the time according to scan hearing
minutes there were some meteorologist
meteorological investigations already
going up on Mount Washington by
companies like GE
and this was viewed as a means to bring
corporations to do additional serious
experiments and bring possible benefits
to New Hampshire
GE documented the experiments they did
on Mount Washington as part of their
history of project Cirrus and the
meetings of the New Hampshire Committee
hearing revealed that the federal
government had a similar bill being
considered by Congress by the Department
of Commerce at the time
in this New Hampshire committee there
were concerns about what would happen if
experiment results drifted into States
like Vermont and Maine
would our state be held liable
but the response was that the statute
covered that it doesn't and at the time
there was some sort of lawsuit pending
in New Hampshire New York City Courts
there were conferences to the cost of
these projects and that ground seating
would be less expensive than air seeding
other comments indicated that
departments like fish and game
and the New Hampshire State Council of
resources and development saw this as
permissive legislation and that fishing
game did a study of habitat and ecology
and showed that controlling the
experiments was possible there was no
explanation of how that would be
others expressed concern about
unqualified people running these
experiments and in the end they all
agreed that the bill was acceptable so
in 1953 it became law
attempted repeal of the current statute
was attempted in 2013 in the house
Science and Technology committee
it failed then because they felt no
value in removing it from statute
I actually attempted repeal and as a
Senate Bill last year but came to
understand that repeal meant the statute
would remain totally silent on the issue
at all which was not really a desired
consequence so here I am today with an
addition to the statute to put in place
public notification
for over 60 years this statute has been
in place and no one has used it and no
one has plans to use it last year I
contacted 13 department heads agencies
and commissions in New Hampshire to see
if they ever used the statute or plan to
use it
Penn replied no and three did not return
my email of many reservations regarding
the statute as it stands today and while
it hasn't seemed to be a bother being in
place for all this time its potential is
disturbing without some sort of public
notification included there's no mention
of having proposals of weather
modification experimentation coming to a
vote or approval from New Hampshire
citizens there's no mention or
limitation of what types of experiments
could be performed experimentation could
result in some pretty devastating health
and ecological Fallout
there's no guarantee of safety to our
state ecology or population there's no
mention of the liability our state would
have when neighboring states and what
problems this could cause our
agricultural Community most people in
New Hampshire have no idea that the
statute even exists and this is why I'd
like to at least add a public
notification element so that if plans do
come about then the citizens of the
state can at least be informed about
them ahead of time and have an
opportunity to comment
there are many articles and websites
which discuss the ability of man to
control weather
especially in these times when we are
concerned about changes in our climate
and weather patterns I'm no scientist
but in reading up on the subject more
and more scientists agree that
controlling the weather is nearly
impossible because of the huge list of
variables involved however for a long
time there's been experimentation going
on in small and large scale with some of
that the public is aware of and some not
the truth is that despite experiments
and studies over the decades it is still
challenging to carry out such controlled
experiments and difficult to ascertain
if they will actually work
the jury is still out on whether or not
these experiments are favorable to the
planet
or can create undesirable effects in the
long term
no one is really sure what releasing
various chemicals into the air will do
to everything below or if there are
long-term consequences
so the statute that we currently have is
so Broad and gives carte blanche to the
state on this issue of weather
experimentation I'm not convinced that
allowing departments and agencies in our
state to have unfettered ability to do
weather modification experiments in the
Skies over New Hampshire is a good or
safe thing
but we should at the very least insert
public input into the process
and so I hope that you will
consider this bill and and give it an
OTP and I am happy to take any of your
questions
to representative shewitt
thank you Mr chair
um thank you representative Aaron for
taking my question
um you mentioned possible effects on
particular neighboring states do you
know if any other states have such a law
and particularly if they have this
notification element in their law if
um I
I believe they do uh there's a couple of
States out west I I'd have to dig
through some of my notes to see
um
there was a a a a woman who testified
her name was Amy Vickers uh last year
and she indicated that there were some
other states that did have uh some
statute which
uh discussed the um you know
climate experimentation weather
experimentation and some of the um
uh you know safeguards that they had in
place
representative
thank you Mr chair
representative Aaron do you know of any
uh
done in New Hampshire on this
uh from thank you for your question I I
appreciate that um
I have spoken uh emailed several uh like
I said uh uh 10 uh 13 uh department
heads and that was uh let's see I spoke
with
um the department of safety uh
Department of Fish and Game uh division
of force and lands uh information
technology department of Agriculture uh
unh's agriculture experimentation
station and a few others and they all
indicated to me that they have never
their agency never used the statute they
don't have any plans of any
weather experimentation or modification
and they actually had no use for the
statute at all so when I first inquired
about
repealing the statute they were all okay
with it because they said we never used
this in the 60 years we've had this on
the books and we don't see anything
coming
um but I do know that that there has
been some talk
about weather experimentation
uh from the federal government and of
course New Hampshire would have to work
in conjunction with any of the federal
government
uh programs but to date there hasn't
been any uh anything done that I'm aware
of
um or that these uh department heads are
aware of
and so
um but it doesn't that doesn't mean that
thank you Mr chair
um representative Aaron
um
you mentioned that there had has been
sometime in the past experimentation
that people don't even know about so I'm
wondering if
um some of that has been or in the
future could be done by companies or
individuals and is there anything in our
statutes that deals with that because
this seems to do to deal with state
agencies
yeah I don't know I mean
the original reason why this statute was
put in place was you know they were they
were talking about uh you know when when
New Hampshire had any kind of drought
conditions in the winter that they might
need to see the clouds to do uh you know
bring snow
and of course nowadays we have snow
making machines at our at our ski areas
so we don't really need to do anything
to kind of fiddle around with weather
but that was kind of the impetus in the
1950s when this all came about was you
know to help the state if we ever had
any kind of drought conditions
um but
I don't know really of any companies
that have done anything on a smaller
scale and that's the thing is we just
don't know I don't know if there's
anything through the Department of
Environmental Protection or I mean
Environmental Services through Des
or Health and Human Services where any
particular
um
you know any particular uh companies
have done anything on their own
and I don't know that they need any kind
um
[Music]
Mr chair I can't
um understand I can you're loud enough
but it's very garbled I can't understand
the words
I was just clarifying I feel like uh
representative fellows was asking you if
your bill does anything to um notify the
public
yeah
anybody representative Erin did you hear
that
can everyone hear me I'm sorry sorry
about that
I was trying to ask you and for my own
clarification
does your bill do anything to notify the
public of a private company were to
decide to do anything whatsoever
no um perhaps that's something that the
[Music]
thank you Mr chair this is more of a
question of the chair
um the last time this bill went forward
to
in 2013 to repeal this went to Science
and Tech and this seems like it's more
of their purview than ours can we get
some input from them before we vote on
this as to how they feel about this
I think that's a good idea
representative McGuire before we call an
executive
[Music]
the the other thing here
just just think about what you said
representative goalie
um you know this isn't Edna is not being
asked to modify any of the technical
aspects of this I think this bill from
what I can really tell just really only
is asking for uh public notification
and that's that's the gist of what this
okay representative of a Bryant
uh thank you Mr chairman uh and
representative Aaron thank you for
taking my question uh can you just
explain why you went this route uh
basically in my reading of the bill it
is to have them notify uh make sure that
the public is notified that they're
doing any of these experimentations but
why didn't you go for perhaps maybe
trying to get a permit which would have
gave to the state more authority to look
at it instead of just a notification the
notification
will probably just say I'm gonna go do
it but applying for the permit could be
denied if it was so contrary in that
vein if you choose to answer that
question please
yes thank you uh representative O'Brien
I appreciate that well you know I looked
at the statute to begin with and and
really the way the statute reads is that
any department or agency of the state
may with the approval of the governor
and Council and within the limits of
appropriated funds or by means of gift
donations or grants engaged and and
undertake experimentation in the
techniques and methods for weather
modification and may cooperate therein
with the federal government with
authorized agencies of other states and
with interested persons and
organizations
this statute doesn't talk anything about
applying for permits I don't even know
if we have a permitting process through
Des
or Department of Health and Human
Services or any of that
I don't believe they do I think this the
way the statute is written is just that
the agency heads would come out would
have some kind of weather modification
program or plan and take it to the
executive Council and the governor and
you know I since there's no permitting
process that I see in place at all
uh there was nothing there to
amend and I didn't think I had any kind
of
[Music]
um
knowledge enough about you know creating
a permitting process
but the least the very least that I
wanted to do was to have public input
into the process that exists
thank you for the answer thank you Mr
chairman
representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman uh well first of
all I'd like to Second representative
goalie's suggestion that we uh contact
the talk with uh st e uh with regard to
their previous actions on this bill but
uh representative Aaron's information uh
that uh governor and Council have to uh
get involved and and uh and approve this
to me that that's all the control that
we need I don't think of the
notification concept is a bad idea uh
because I think the public certainly
should be aware of if the state is
setting about
tinkering with our weather uh it's
already enough of a problem just with
the natural course of things but uh if
the governor or Council have to approve
before anything goes forward on behalf
of the state
um then that's as much control as as we
probably need that is public input
through the executive counselors and uh
the governor of course but
um
I think we're good to go with
uh thank you chair appreciate that any
further questions uh representative
Aaron
see none does he representative Aaron
thank you for your testimony is anyone
Mr chairman can I just interject briefly
um I think you need to to pull back a
little bit from the mic you're leaning
into it just a bit too much and that's
causing a little bit of um Distortion
thanks trying to find that sweet spot
um exactly
the chair of us recognizes
representative Silva
representative would you uh like to
you'll have to unmute yourself there we
go I think I've got it now right yeah
good morning uh I'm representative Mike
Sylvia from Belknap uh six town of
Belmont and I just want to do uh briefly
jump in and uh in support of the bill
I think this is uh important for uh
transparency
uh and our constitution Aristotle
demands that we uh we provide
transparency to our citizens and uh most
of us wouldn't have even known about
this uh this bill and the Bill of the
policy of weather modification and
certainly uh if something like that is
going to be put forward
we certainly want to have enough uh
notice of it that we can really look
into it as best we can
thank you any questions from
[Music]
okay uh the chair record is representing
good morning everyone thank you for the
opportunity and um I've been on a lot of
webinars I have to admit this is the
first time I've been on Zoom so
apologies if there's any issues here
um just want to thank all of you and
particularly um representative Aaron I
just learned about the bill being
introduced again
um as I said last year when I spoke
briefly
um I'm an engineer I'm based in Amherst
Massachusetts
I work as a consultant to large and
small water utilities in the U.S and
overseas on water efficiency issues and
I have become educated in recent years
about the extent of wild seating that
goes on particularly among water
utilities so briefly I'm strongly in
support of this bill I think if you pass
it New Hampshire will really be a
Pioneer in the area of public
notification about weather modification
it's an increasing practice there's some
controversy about it I think no matter
which side of the debate you're on I
think we can all agree that the public
has a right to know this is going on
um and I think there's a lot of
scientific evidence to indicate that
weather modification activities in one
area can affect whether in another area
right now in New England to my knowledge
at least there's not a lot if any
weather modification going on but I
think as the years go on we may see that
change the technology of whether
modification is advancing quickly and I
think water suppliers here may start to
look at that as an option as well and
again that has an impact not just on the
immediate water supply so briefly those
are my comments and again I strongly
encourage you to support this bill and
it would be a real boost to um public
information thank you
thank you uh will you take questions Mr
Speaker
Mr Speaker because we take questions oh
yes I will pardon me yes
thing going on and can you tell us where
that has happened is you know
um if you do an internet search you put
in cloud seating I think at least in the
United States you'll see it's mostly
west of the Mississippi but but if you
drill down and look at some of the
different weather modification or cloud
seeding companies most of them are based
in the west but you'll see examples of
weather modification activities in the
East for example the last time I looked
at one company there were weather
modification activities going on in
Delaware
um you know again if you get an update
I'm sure you'd see different information
but Cloud sitting is used for many many
things today water supply agriculture
hail suppression military
so again I can't speak to New England
right now I know historically there were
experiments here
um but I I don't have the latest
information
any further questions Mrs Vickers
you've seen none is there anything else
being none to go ahead and post a public
hearing
point of order I also I would like to um
discuss this with Des before we accept
the bill so I'll do that this week but I
just wanna I have some environment and
some Environmental Conservation
questions to ask of them
and the chair would be happy if you
shared your information with us thank
you
thank you this this bill is not a
science bill this bill is in Russian
committee
sections
Madam chair I couldn't understand half
of what you were saying sorry I was that
I will confer with the chair of science
technology and energy and confirm that
they have no interest in the current
status because there's no technical
issues and we will not execute today
is
representative Judy is representative
representative Judy are you out there
[Music]
Mr chairman
House Bill 567
[Music]
was
the intent of it was to have a
proclamation done declaring February 5th
2021 as Apollo 14 day in honor of the
50th anniversary of the Apollo 14 lunar
Landing which made Dairy native Allen
Bartlett Shepard Jr the fifth person to
walk on the moon
and the only person to hit a golf ball
oon
as you uh
as you would imagine February 5th 2021
has come and gone and the governor's
office was gracious enough to
take care of this
unnecessary and subject to uh all kinds
of fun possibilities
[Music]
yes thank you Mr chair
the this bill being out of date is even
before the hearing uh I was asked to
look at the executive orders affecting
licensing and see which of them belonged
in statute So after talking with oplc
and some other people
we decided that the executive order
that permitted military personnel EMTs
to apply for licensures and nursing
assistant was a
was something that ought to be in
statute
uh an LNA is the lowest level of
licensed medical personnel
they have a rather limited scope of
practice
EMTs and paramedics in particular are
more than qualified to do what an LMT
does but in New Hampshire their
licensing is restricted to being with an
organization a fire department an
ambulance a hospital they don't work
independently
so what this bill does is it declares
their education
equivalent and allows them to apply for
a license will let which will let them
work in other situations using the same
skills and experience they have before
I know that built that such military
personnel have worked with covet testing
and if you have questions I believe
representative Pearson is a lot more
qualified than I am to answer that
but basically this the amendment says
acknowledges their training and
expertise and says if they want a
license
we'll give them one and they can use it
to do things that an EMS license will
doesn't
okay
um
[Music]
thank you uh I don't know who to direct
the question to perhaps uh
representative Pearson uh but from my
experience and I'm sure it's very
similar in other communities perhaps
even yours uh some of the firefighters I
use already using their EMT EMT Advanced
Training and working in the hospital and
I just want to make sure that nothing
with this amendment would jeopardize
them in that type of occupation of uh
working to advance their Medical Careers
no it shouldn't all this all this does
is it allows them to have the an LMT
license in addition to their EMS license
with its full scope of practice
thank you Mr chair representative
McGuire I just want to make sure that
the um
it allows them to apply for licensure
but it they must meet the current
requirements
of that position correct
yes if this says that they can use their
training and experience instead of the
LNA training and experience but they
must
um
not have committed various crimes and
whatever
and
they have to pay the fee
anyone wish else wish to testify on this
amendment
chair recognizes Mr Broderick
foreign
good morning can you all hear me yes
great good morning um acting chairman
Roy and members of the committee for the
record I'm Tom Broderick legal counsel
for the oplc or the office of
professional licensure and certification
um the oplc provides administrative and
clerical support record keeping keeping
services and business processing for the
54 occupational licensing boards
commissions and councils under its
umbrella I'm here on behalf of the oplc
2021-0276h I want to be clear first
while the amendment primarily affects
the board of nursing which is under
oplc's umbrella I'm speaking now on
behalf of oplc only uh not on behalf of
the Board of Nursing or any of the other
boards so as represent representative
McGuire had stated this amendment would
codify emergency order number 78 which
provides an alternative rights route to
licensure as a licensed nursing
assistant or LNA to those with either
certain military experience or
individuals a certain EMT or paramedical
paramedic licenses and experience
my understanding the is that the
emergency order was issued in response
to an LNA shortage in New Hampshire that
shortage has been particularly
concerning due to the pandemic but again
my understanding is that New Hampshire
has faced a shortage of lnas even in
non-pandemic times so this amendment is
meant to help alleviate that issue not
just during the pandemic But continuing
past that
oplc's been in contact with Justin
romanello the bureau chief at the
department of safety's division of fire
standards and training in Emergency
Medical Services he's indicated that his
division supports this amendment as well
um
so lastly oplc has been issuing LNA
licensees to licenses to those with
these credentials since the emergency
order came into effect in late December
I was anticipating that the committee
may have questions about the number of
licenses we've issued under this
emergency order I've reached out to our
licensing team to find out how many have
been issued but I haven't heard back yet
so if you're curious I can get that
information to you I really don't have
any more points to make but I'm happy to
take any questions
foreign
follows
um yes I just thank you Mr chair I just
wanted to say that I would like to know
how many so if he can email us that
would be great sure
representative shewitt
thank you
um my question is probably of the chair
um I noticed that uh the list that Ms
smarling sent out showed eight people
had signed in and support and two in
opposition and I'm curious if there's
any way to tell if those sign-ins were
actually directed towards the original
bill or towards the non-germaine
amendment
both were noticed so
um I I suppose there's really no way to
tell but both were noticed
thank you I I did see the notice for the
amendment like I said I was just the
Curious the non-germaine amendment was
separately posted from the bill so that
if somebody signed in
on the basic bill that's I would presume
that's what they intended to do
thank you that's something we may want
to look at for future to to make it
clear if someone has an opinion on
particularly a non-germaine Amendment
we'd be able to know thank you
thank you
um representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman uh so and Mr
Broderick if you're still on on the line
uh I I also would be interested in the
statistical information you referenced
earlier uh I I know that one of our
former Dover firefighters uh was
regularly employed at uh or on duty at
me I could say it for sure uh at the
when was Douglas Hospital emergency room
not just on an emergency basis but it
was there over a period of months uh
quite regularly uh so to the degree that
we have a shortage
um yeah this this is something I would
definitely be interested in more
information on so that we can know uh
how best to proceed because I say I
think these people are eminently
qualified and we should support this
thank you
thank you representative uh the chair
would like to ask a question the
licenses that have been issued
um for what length are they are they
good for are they issued for the
standard amount of time a license would
be or is there a shorter time period
based on the pandemic in the emergency
order
so
um unfortunately I don't have the
emergency order pulled up but the uh the
my memory is that they are valid for
perhaps three or four months past the
uh past the end of the state of
Governors declared state of emergency
I'd have to double check that but it's
of limited duration because these
license are coming from an emergency
order
I think that was that's all I wanted to
know thank you very much
is she none is anyone else for some
testified on this bill
[Music]
they're being also none I'm going to
close public hearing on this bill
and the next bill will not be till one
o'clock
now one o'clock
so the committee will be in recess until
1pm hold on oh the wheelchair would like
to say something
a couple of things first of all we are
in session on Wednesday and Thursday
it will be approximately nine to five on
Wednesday and nine to two on Thursday
because I have another customer after we
get out on Thursday
I have the consultation with
representative goalie signed up the
authors of all of the blurbs to defend
the committee position and he and I are
splitting the pis if they're if they're
if any of the bills come off consent or
have debate
the only debate that I am sure of is on
House Bill 274 which all of you are well
and
I wanted to make sure that was the case
and what else I've got calendars for the
people in that are here in case they
is there any questions
um
I guess I did The Minority Report on the
motion
okay as a member of The Minority Report
I was the author of The Minority Report
you are essentially leading the
opposition to the committee position so
that if you choose to speak or to get
someone else to speak
it's your responsibility
I've signed up the representative
fellows to defend the committee position
and representative bowley will do the pi
[Music]
okay
do you need to do business with you now
I think that if there it would be a good
idea to use this uh hour and a half or
so to consider if there are any about
the bills we would like to object that
we've heard in previous immunities
or like a feeler is there any interest
in exactly what we just literally talked
about with 567.
no I'm not interested in that thank you
oh 567 I'm so sorry
Steve
on what the number of licenses that he
gave no that's from oplc uh if that's
the one you want to talk about yes I'm
happy with that yeah okay
567. literally with that
in that case if you have a motion
representative Pearson
Amendment 027
. that's representative Schultz took
you wish to speak to your motion sure uh
just just for those in representative
goli and certainly representative
O'Brien and even representative lindsar
can
touch on this as well when it you know
the the scope of practice that they're
talking about here as far as equivalency
goes
um even EMT basics in the state of New
Hampshire have
more field
standing order Authority than an LNA
does so so this is really not a matter
of worrying about qualifications that's
that's certainly um
certainly well covered this is just a a
matter of an extreme need that is
occurring right now and the ability to
have folks that are
more than qualified and experienced to
to fill that need as uh
as we move forward through the pandemic
and even even beyond that so
I think this is a no-brainer it's
it's very very uh straightforward and I
would encourage all to uh to support
this
Schultz would you like to speak to your
second
I explained it very well the need is
high and this is a good thing
um and I think the need is going to
continue I mean as the uh
as the you know population agents
there's probably going to be more need
than we have now so I think it's a good
idea
is that first on Bailey do you have a
question
nope
okay uh on seeing anyone
in that case the motion is ought to pass
Amendment zero two seven six H by
for the adoption of the amendment
0276h representative Roy yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative yakubovic
yes
representative leckis yes representative
Allegro yes
representative
yes representative goalie
yes
representative shuitt
yes representative Trudy are we
representative Schmidt yes
representative Schultz with all due
deference to the Apollo missions yes
representative fellows
yes
representative Fontenot yes
representative O'Brien
yes and the chair yes
19-0 for adoption of the amazing
Pearson you have an emotion
sure um since this is a non-termain
Amendment and it's a complete rewrite I
Pres
the procedure to go forward is still the
same as far as octopus with Amendment on
five six seven all right is there a
second
by representative Schmidt thank you
is there any further discussion
shouldn't be since the amendment was
released the bill anyone
so he said it all it's a no-brainer
okay in that case the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment 0276
the clerk can follow the rule
representative Roy yes the clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative yakubovic
yes
representative blackis yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
one Zara yes
representative santospaso
yes
representative goalie
yes representative shuitt yes
representative Judy
wait
representative Schmidt yes
representative Schultz yes
representative fellows yes
representative yes
yes
representative O'Brien yes
and the chair yes the same 19-0
hey
excellent
yes
Pearson
House Bill 631 does somebody have a
motion
probably
like I was unavailing you wonder what I
gotta figure out what that one is that's
the deaf and Harden here all right uh
there's an amendment that needs to be
between
copies of the amendment have been
distributed and we're down in the
committee room last week but everybody
should at least have an electronic copy
yes
they were last week I didn't know what
you were planning on executing today so
I I did not um know that you wanted the
that Amendment what's the bills remember
zero four three nine h
House Bill 631 was the one I was
drinking out
it's deaf and harder here for the deaf
and hard of hearing what was the
amendment against
manman was zero four three nine H that's
what I add my notes thank you
okay
if we don't have a motion to move I'll
I'll move to recommend house bill
I mean I'm sorry I mean the amendment to
the bill do we have emotion I can't
quite figure out where we are no that's
where I'm trying to figure out I'll make
it okay representative Pearson makes the
motion okay what's the past and brings
out Amendment
oh four three nine H is that correct
yeah
you can explain it I can explain it
because I'm familiar with it okay during
the hearing
on House Bill 631 there was a request
made by one of the um
one of the groups that's involved to be
added to a list of folks that are
currently recognized in that Community
this amendment
does just that it adds those folks onto
that list and that would be lines 20 on
page two lines 27 is the uh
the group and it was the association of
late deafened adults in the Northeast
theft and hard of hearing Services Inc
as requested during the
and I'm the executive director of
navigating recruit the Lakes Region we
apons
maybe that's Pam Sterling there we go
thank you
thank you so so as you the amendment
representative
earlier than that
yes thank you somebody else so when all
of us wrote the amendment they they
basically just it seems like they did it
as a rewrite almost it's not it's just
that's why it looks so lengthy
as I'm going through this they just
basically added that part and then
rewrote the whole the whole thing
instead of just doing it as a line this
is just a copy of the existing bill that
went again
yeah okay yeah I can't see any other
wheel okay
[Music]
are you speaking to the
doing something
that is the uh
that is the amendment it's the addition
like I said page two line 28 of the
Northeast deaf and hard of hearing
services
thank you
representative goalie do you wish to
I think representative Pearson spoke
well of the uh intent of the amendment
and I will support
thank you is there any further questions
seeing none in that case the motion is
to adopt Amendment
0439h and the clerk can pull the rules
representative Roy yeah
clerk puts yes representative Pearson
yes representative yakubovic
yes
representative leckis yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
London Zara yes
representative Santo nastasso
yes
representative goalie yes
representative should yes representative
Judy we
representative Schmidt
yes
representative Schultz yes
representative fellows
yes
representative Funk no yes
representative Grodin yes
representative O'Brien yes
and the chair yes
19-0 in adoption is the amendment right
excellent
does someone have a motion on the bill
yeah I'll make the motion for auto
passes amended
right
seeing non-hearing none the motion is
ought to pass with amendments and the
clerk can follow the rules
are you out there
uh the vote
yes okay thank you
uh representative lycus yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes
representative lanzara yes
Representatives
yes representative goalie
yes
representative should
yes representative Judy we
representative Schmidt yes
yes sorry
okay representative fellows
yes
yes representative yes
representative Rhoda
yes representative O'Brien
I feel like this yeah sure yes okay yes
HP 452 ought to pass
[Music]
uh that's uh precluding the Secretary of
State for running for another office
second
are there any would you like to speak to
just briefly I think it's a good idea to
have the person in charge of making sure
the elections are are run correctly from
being uh part of the election that needs
do you wish to speak to your second
yeah it seems like a good bill
eliminates conflict of interest
any uh other comments questions another
Allegro you have a couple questions no
thank you madam chair
um even though the situation in New
Hampshire is somewhat different than
most of the states where secretaries of
state are elected directly and ours is
elected indirectly as we know
nevertheless the idea of the person
who's conducting the election and who
has Authority with regard to
people who are registered to vote or
purging the voter rolls and so forth
there's a clear conflict of interest
we've seen it in several instances in
other states
and even though we don't think that
represent that Secretary of State Bill
Gardner is going to be running for
anything else anytime soon
um I I think this is a strong statement
in favor of uh transparency and and
integrity of the process so I'm going to
thank you is there anyone else who
yeah I'd like to mention the timing is
right because as representative Schmidt
says Secretary of State Gardener is not
likely to run for for elected office
again and any new secretary of state
would know this going into the position
representative I'm out of step on this
I'm going to vote against the motion
because I've this basically says the
public is going to be Bamboozled by
seeing his signature and golly we have
to vote for him I don't subscribe to it
at all and I I just don't want to
subscribe to that uh I hope that effect
doesn't exist uh I don't want to see
anybody precluded from running for
another office by virtue holding one
office so I'll be out of step on this
all right representative
um at least
from what I've been thinking that that's
that's not the issue of people being bad
bull Super Bowl it's just the uh
hopefully only appearance and and who
knows uh possibly real conflict of
interest where you've got
someone who is running for an office
um
you know but also have some trouble with
what's going on so that's not a good
idea in general even if the person is a
perfect Integrity it just doesn't look
good representative I might point out
that the Secretary of State runs for the
um but he's you know his electorate is
the legislature and it's it's a little
different than a general election
the bill also lists specifically the uh
positions that the
Secretary of State could not run for
it does not include secretaries
I'm citing that only for the Integrity
issue all that business
secretary of state doesn't run the
secretary of state election
any other comments appearance if I may
Madam chair I was hoping that we might
retain the bill because I think the bill
is um is important but I'm not so sure
that
we've had enough of a discussion of it
and have been enough
I'd like to know a little bit I'd like
to think more about this bill
because I do think that the bill has
Merit
but I think that before we make
such an important decision like this
we do
um
I'd like to feel more secure about our
vote
does that make sense I mean I I don't
see anything wrong with the bill right
now but at the same time I'm not
convinced that this is it encompasses
everything that we wanted to
thank you and yeah
representative Schultz
thank you uh I'd like to piggyback on
what representative scitec said I also
have a problem with this bill because
running for office uh is something that
shouldn't be banned just because of
holding the Secretary of State's
position that's apparent not quite a
paraphrase in what representative scitec
said but I also think it just sends a
bad message to say that
for some reason
we suspect a secretary of state would be
unable to be impartial and do their job
properly if they were running for
another office that implies they're
doing their job improperly that's a
whole there's already a set of laws that
pertain to that and while I'm very aware
of what's happened in other states
um the the Integrity of our elections in
New Hampshire are I believe are
unimpeachable so I don't see
why we have this is a bill in search of
a problem that doesn't exist in the
granite state in my opinion
thank you representative
if I could I just I think it's more
along the lines I don't think it's
because we are we feel like there is
something going on or has gone on I
think it's more along the lines of um if
you think about judicial
um a judge has an obligation to recuse
himself when there's a obvious conflict
or an appearance of a conflict that the
public can can take from it
um the Secretary of State cannot recuse
himself and as such if he decides to run
for governor or or executive counselor
while he's the Secretary of State it's
certainly at least can call into
question the appearance of any propriety
when he's in charge of the very election
that he's running for so I don't think
it's necessarily that that we've we
think he or she or whoever the future
one is is going to do something wrong
it's about the giving confidence to the
public that the office is beyond our
approach
I just heard representative Roy say that
the Secretary of State could not recuse
himself but that I think that's part of
the argument that I'm hearing from
representative scitec and representative
Schultz perhaps we should talk about
this bill further
and put that option in place if it's an
office that the secretary is running for
that he would have the ability to excuse
himself from participating in that
particular election decision so I think
maybe retaining would be a good
um
a good method to at least examine that
possibility thank you
thank you madam chair and I too agree it
and I think this needs to be looked at a
little further
um I understand uh
while he's running for an office he
should not be uh overseeing the election
I also look at nor shall a person
serving as Secretary of State be
eligible for nomination for such an
office
um so if there becomes a vacancy or
something of that nature and he wants to
be he is nominated to go into that
position
um this precludes him from doing that
thank you madam chair it hasn't been
said yet but it should be perfectly
obvious that uh if uh Secretary of State
uh which is not of course we've had the
same Secretary of State for like 40
years uh so we're in a unique situations
Nationwide there's no other Secretary of
State who has served anywhere near as
long as Bill Gardner has but clearly uh
the Secretary of State if he really
wants another office he could always
resign but as long as the secretary of
state is the Secretary of State I don't
think that he or she should be running
for another office is too much of a
conflict events we we've seen it in
other states where uh all kinds of
shenanigans go on
so I'm sticking with the idea that this
bill is a good idea to make sure that we
have integrity of the person who's
running for the Secretary of State who
is the secretary of state is not running
for another office at the same time
thank you representative fellows
wanted to add I'm not especially in
favor of this or not in favor of this
but one thing that we could look at
would be the possibility that if the
Secretary of State announces or gives
his resignation effective
you know at on the election day
if he wanted to he or she wanted to run
for office then that person would not be
this is interesting I I miss most of the
uh hearing but obviously it was livelier
than I thought
okay so the motion is ought to pass by
representative Roy
um
clerky told the rules
uh representative Roy yes
clerk puts no
a little louder I haven't given you an
answer yet
tick tick tick tick yeah tick tick tick
I'm gonna I'm gonna go with no right now
because I wanna
I wanna see what our other
yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes
represent representative blood Zara
no
representative Santo nastasso
yes
representative Schoen
no representative Judy no
representative Schmidt yes
down with the ship representative
Schultz
no
representative fellows
representative no
no
no thank you
representative O'Brien no
8 to 11 the motion fails you're correct
all right I move to routine
five seconds
all right so
does that require a vote Yes it does
that's uh shuitt and who was in broders
any further discussion
like I think that we have seen that uh
there are too many questions with the
bill the way it's written and
um I think retaining is is the best
I think that the bill warrants uh
retention and I think that it's
something that if we work on this will
be something that's better than what we
have now but I don't think that I do
think that having the
um the bill and and passing such a bill
in the long term is good
thank you anyone else
representative Pearson
I think there's there's got to be a way
here to deal with the the concept of a
someone from running for anything I I
think that the the voters should decide
whether a person is acceptable or not
for an office and and I think there's
there with the retention here I think we
could probably find a way to
to
make both things happen
all right thank you
a technical question that is what
happens if we're Team fails
way of order when I'm chair would you
assign a sub committee to the retention
of this bill so that we could work on it
in an Earnest way
uh yes this should probably this would
go to the committee on government
organization which I believe represents
okay we can call it that yeah licensing
sure don't know you're doing license I'm
doing licensing yeah it's representative
Roy yes it's a subcommittee that
representative Roy is leading thank you
it's a similarity yes that's fine
let me I'm going to rock the boat again
this sounds to me like we should all
think about it and talk to each other
about it and do this as a committee of
the whole
I think this is uh not quite a
subcommittee issue
that's my thought I kind of like what
rep for example representative fellows
I'm not sure I'm buying it but it was an
interesting idea uh resignation of the
day of I want to think about that kind
of thing I don't know that some
committee is the way to go my thoughts
in any event we won't do anything with
it until after crossover for sure and
probably not till
uh August I think is the earliest we can
yes representative Judy
uh
my my my question been answered thank
you
this question has been answered oh
excellent okay anyone else wish to
comment the motion is to retain
by representative shuitt and uh
clerk control the rule
on retention representative Roy yes the
clerk puts yes representative Pearson
yes representative yakubovic
no
representative leicus yes representative
Allegro yes
represented daily yes representative
lanzara
yes
representative goalie
representative should
yes
representative Trudy we representative
Schmidt
unenthusiastically yes
I'll write it very lightly
representative Schultz
a milk toast no
no
representative Fontenot yes
representative Grodin
canceling Representatives
unenthusiastic yes to an enthusiastic
yes
we've made it darker representative
O'Brien
playing yes
and the chair
now
15 years four Nays
all right it is retained we will work on
it at some later point and uh
congratulations no committee report is
due on this bill
yes
I would like to mention that
that was just my attempt to get rid of
some low-hanging fruit so I'm pretty
open either way on that bill but if
anyone has ideas let's start cobbling
together so then we'll get this bill
back again we're not
casting above
[Music]
sorry you kind of faded out Terry what
did you say on that
thinking about what that's my question
thinking about what that bill should say
oh I like the way it says what it says
now which apparently many of us don't
so should we um send our recommendations
into
um Pam Sparling so that we have a
depository that where we can keep by our
ideas
you're welcome to send any comments or
suggestions to the committee uh if that
and Pam if asked Pam will put probably
put them in the billfold
thank you
does anyone else have emotion on any
representative Schultz you have a motion
I have an amendment I'm not sure that
everybody saw it
no I have not
in that case would you make sure to
distribute the amendment we'll take it
[Music]
believe it's different than Leo
television
huh
it is and I'm not sure I have fully
vetted it
um with a few folks
um
I would like to request that we exec it
on the next time we exec stuff
the next time we exec things will be
Friday
we have two bills posted for exec and
we'll fill in with as many others as we
can get to all right
well in that case I will move
ought to pass on House Bill 369 with
Amendment
0185h
do you give me that number again please
House Bill
369. sorry the amendment one eight five
second
so as a mover I will say that this bill
is was a request by professional
licensure certification to clarify uh
the use of of what they call Pam and to
eliminate an extra layer of
certification that they do not believe
is needed the amendment was developed by
the Board of Occupational therapists and
they're in full support
and it's it's a little simpler and it
allows them to use
their training and experience
representative Allegra would you care to
speak to your second
I think you encapsulated everything I
would say it's it's uh just a case of
simplifying uh something that's desired
the
Madam chair can you please explain I'm
so sorry I I I must have missed that
amendment can you could you please
explain how the amendment amends the
original bill
okay it
see it's under rule making
it
adds the
um
these these techniques with ultrasound
or lead electrical physical agent uh
physical agent modalities
and it's it just allows them to make
rules about about them and how they are
used and if
I remember the amendment now I'm sorry
it rang a bell after you started talking
thank you
very good
and basically it allows them to do
and now I'm sure if I may just point out
that
um I believe the amendment was put
forward by that specific board within
oplc yes it was I thought I said that
I think you just said oplc but I I just
wanted to clarify that it it was by the
board that deals with this profession
specifically
um
there's no other questions or comments
the motion is to adopt Amendment 0185
and prescription
representative Pearson yes
representative yakubovic yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Allegro yes representative Bailey yes
representative lanzara yes
representative Santo nastasso
representative goalie yes representative
sure
yes representative Judy we
representative Schmitz yes
representative uh Schultz yes
representative Salos
representative yes
representative groda yes representative
O'Brien yes
and the chair yes 19-0
right then I move off to pass with
you like seeing none the motion is ought
to pass with Amendment and the clerk can
call the rules representative Wright
yeah represent other clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative yakubovic yes
representative leckis yes representative
Allegro yes representative Bailey yes
representative lanzara yes
representative Santo nastasso
representative goalie yes representative
yes
is that me uh yes I couldn't hear thank
you representative Schultz now
representative Schmidt yes
representative fellows
representative
yes
representative Grodin
representative O'Brien yes
and the chair yes
the same 19-0 does anyone object to
consent
does anyone else have emotion that they
want to bring forward
Madam chair you think we're ready for an
about Atlantic Standard Time
uh that's a valid motion we will
definitely
um I'll just say I made my case
uh last week week before last it's kind
of a blur
um
I don't want to reiterate my speech I
think folks have fairly strong opinions
on this but I will just say that
um I think overall it would just be a
great benefit
and I encourage folks who maybe are
inclined to oppose it to talk to their
constituents
thank you uh manager I am
I think that this is a good bill and
it's it's a starter I think obviously
nothing's going to happen unless the
domino effect we heard about starts and
if someone doesn't push the first Domino
it's never going to happen so I think
this is a good start and it may spur the
federal uh legislators to actually do
something so I think it's a good place
to start
[Music]
um I oppose this bill
um one of the my concerns is that it's
purported to have health benefits but
the reason in in specifically people
talk about heart attacks and strokes but
people have heart attacks and strokes
because they have high blood pressure
they have
um blockage of the arteries they have
high cholesterol and to think that
um
one losing one hour of sleep would cause
them to have a heart attack is just
makes no sense there's no common sense
to that uh there are issues related to
safety related driving and
um particularly commuters in the morning
because with this bill should should it
ever work its way all the way through
the process
will result in the sun coming up one
hour later
in the winter there's no impact on the
summer at all one hour later in the
winter and as somebody who commuted 40
miles each way to work for 30 years the
conditions of the road in the winter
cause a lot of traffic accidents and
because the snow clouds haven't had a
chance to clear away the snow
far more issues with safety in the
morning than in the evening and those
are those are just two of the points um
students
uh will be waiting for school in the
dark in the morning they're they're
already waiting in the dark in some
places it'll be darker for men for many
more months
and one of the things issue that was
raised by one of the speakers is that
um
has to do with students
going to school later high school
students I think it's well documented
that high school students have a very
hard time waking up in the morning
and
um it's just it just has to do with
hormones and this will actually be
asking them to wake up even one more
hour earlier
so those are the things I have to say
thank you thank you representative
goalie
thank you madam chair I too will not
support the OTP on this
um we heard in testimony that in
Atlantic time
um the latest we see Sunrise would be at
8 24 A.M
I mean it's not getting light out until
eight o'clock in the morning kids
standing out by the bus stops at 7 A.M
um I think in the dark is inappropriate
um
it's a that's a that's a late Sunrise we
also also heard that
this was like comparing apples to
oranges and some of the pieces of
legislation written
in other states other states are looking
to do away with daylight savings this is
moving us to the Atlantic time zone
totally different than what we're trying
to correlate between states
so for that reason
um as well as the fact that as we hear
about health reasons and health issues
because of
moving the clocks forward and back
um people do that all the time when they
travel they travel into different time
zones and we don't hear of a severe
health impact to those folks that are
traveling so for those reasons I will
not support you out fast thank you
representative Sherwood
thank you madam chair
um I too am not in support of this
specific bill
um I would favor doing away with
daylight savings time but my preference
would be the Eastern Time Zone as our
constant I think the argument that we
heard from the broadcasters Association
was quite relevant regardless of what
representative Pearson said I would I
would just point out that I think if we
change to a completely different time
than New York's Zone we could be in
danger that they just plain would not
send some of those programs to us
because they wouldn't be reaching the
market that their advertisers would be
looking for so he wouldn't have them
available to tape I think that the
health issues that have been raised are
in regards more to the changing back and
forth rather than to the specific time
zone that we settle on so I kind of
discount that argument so I will be
voting no on this
all right if someone comes in and says
let's make it Eastern Time Zone I would
probably be willing to come after that
thank you we're already in the Eastern
um number of points one is uh the
concern of the broadcasters I mean given
well this bill only mentions uh Maine
and Massachusetts given that
Massachusetts
the third existing legislation uh
mentions Connecticut I believe Rhode
Island and Connecticut depends on New
York this wouldn't go into effect unless
New York State changed and you know that
would give a large enough market that I
don't think it's going to be a problem
for the broadcasters at that point so
we'd be fine
um and as representative Roy said
um you know even if it doesn't go to
effect it might act as a push for uh
Congress to do something I don't
understand the uh concern about Eastern
versus I mean Eastern staying on
daylight savings time or Atlantic I mean
the times would be identical it's just
changing the name
so
um I don't understand why some people
like that maybe I'm missing something
as far as the schools uh you know kids
uh going to school in the dark
um there's no reason why if that's a
problem the schools can't decide to
start an hour later
as far as I know
and as far as the health stuff and
people are saying the travel doesn't
cause problems I mean it's generally
known that travel across time zones
actually does cause stress and uh I
don't have any statistics but stress is
known to uh exacerbate various health
problems including heart issues so
so I don't think you can take that as a
and also it's a small segment of the
population it'll do that every year
instead of the entire population which
you know includes people that don't
travel and maybe physically can't travel
because of their health so this would
affect dramatically more people than
traveling so I mean given all that I do
support this
um
and I think it's good to at least get
you know push this along and see what
happens
um yes I I think yeah I think there are
no technological issues people will have
electricity this Century so Machinery
they can figure out what time it is on
computers TV stations should be able to
figure it out I'm a co-sponsor on this
bill I will vote for it
to stop the switching
thank you thank you representative
Pearson
thank you madam chair let's let's not
get confused uh you know the old saying
is
um you know you want to find out what's
actually going to go on read the bill
this is a this is a me too Bill okay
this is not the state of New Hampshire
moving to the Atlantic time zone
for the sake of moving to the time zone
you know when you look at
especially the middle part of it lines
18 19 20. this requires Maine and
Massachusetts to make the move so from
an economic standpoint
the state of New if Maine and
Massachusetts moved to the Atlantic time
zone what choice do we have we are so
Reliant economically
as a region simply because New England
so the states are so small
that this would be massively problematic
to have made in New Hampshire being at
different times than New Hampshire so
this is not it's not confuses here this
isn't us just going off on our own here
this is us saying that hey when when the
the crazy flow chart begins to to drop
the dominoes
that we fall in line with that and you
know as far as the broadcasters go
yeah
Canada has more time zones than we do
when they figure out how to do it up
there the Boston Market is you know this
isn't
Sheboygan here this the Boston media
Market is substantial so
you know with with the
most television broadcasts not being
live anymore
I I just I don't really see the this
being such a massive struggle to watch
TV anyway so let's not forget what the
bill says and what it doesn't say you
know we're not like I said we're not
doing this on our own this is this is
involving actions about the begin in a
regional effort so I will support it
representative Allegra yeah much of what
I was going to say has just been said
but I want to emphasize again what uh
representative Pearson and lekka said
um
it's it's more of a lack of interest in
adapting to the new situation than it is
uh that it's going to cause uh
well in the words of the the broadcast
industry Representatives
the change would be frightening
cataclysmic and a crushing blow and when
I hear that I can't help but think of uh
you know the change in the Millennium uh
21 years ago uh people just had to adapt
I can't believe that with what we have
in terms of computers we can't figure
out how to adjust our programming
and the other thing is it may be a
relatively minor point but we do stick
out into the Atlantic Ocean and uh so
this
Bill actually reflects astrophysical
reality and the rest of it is really
just man-made and can be adjusted so
I'll I tend to support this book
thank you representative font now
thank you I too will support this bill
in theory if uh if nothing else I I
support the illumination of the time
changes and whether that's done by
switching to Atlantic time staying with
eastern Time or eliminating daylight
savings time I don't have a preference
as to how they do it I think there were
enough safeguards in this bill because
of the Domino
effects of the other states that um is
it more will
um the show our intent to support those
changes so I'll support it
thank you representative scitec
uh Madam chair I really don't like going
last you're not oh oh good okay because
I'm going to support it and everything I
wanted to say has been said
but the only thing I want to do that's
helpful is before it representative
Schmidt says that uh it's daylight
saving there's no s on that word
appreciate the great correction
okay I believe that's everyone who has
yet to speak and yes I know you can stop
raising your hands if you want to speak
again I bet you down
okay
uh representative Schmidt is the last
person who hasn't yet spoken so do you
have the floor
okay after it representing scitec has
stolen my thunder uh yes this is an
especially an annoyance to me to hear it
called daylight savings time when it's
called Daylight Saving Time Savings or
something else uh but I I sponsored a
similar Bill like 17 or 18 years ago so
uh this is a concept with whose Time Has
Come uh no pun intended but the reality
is has been said several times but
nothing will happen in New Hampshire
until uh Massachusetts has made up its
mind and if it goes we gotta go we do
not want to be out of sync with
Massachusetts uh with the interlinking
of our economies and as far as the
school student situation school time is
something which can and should be
adjusted this is something which our
Educators have been complaining about
for years saying that early School times
are not not healthy don't make any sense
it's time to get for the school
districts and so forth to get off the
dime and get on time so this is
something we should get in sync with
because if it matches goes we have to be
ready to go
all right new new person heard from
representative Baroda
thank you so while I was listening to
everyone I thought what happens if
States decide to eliminate daylight
saving time and just no change the clock
at all
rather than going to Atlantic time I
heard two different people testifying on
that and one said we can do it no
problem the other one says it would take
an act of Congress and I'm not sure
which I believe but yeah they mentioned
the 1966 permanent time zone yes I think
if we wanted to go to permanent daylight
saving time we would have to have an act
of Congress we want to go to Atlantic
Standard time we could do it without
such a vote but in any event the
arguments about being out of phase with
Massachusetts still apply
thank you
okay on the repeats representative
Schultz
I actually had new information even
though I'm tempted to re-argue my points
as always
um I'm consistent anyways um
so first of all I meant to send two
pieces of research out one was that
responding to Scott spradling's very
good uh testimony even though it opposed
my bill I really took him seriously
there actually is a lot of of literature
out there maybe it's more on the opinion
genre but broadcasters across the
country are frustrated that the whole
time zone discussion around broadcasters
actually has a significant Eastern Time
Zone bias and so that will always be
occurring for every other group not in
the Eastern Time Zone I meant to send
some of that literature or at least a
link to one or two of those opinion
stories about that the second bit of
research that I meant to was to clarify
my answer to representative goalie's
point about traveling and time zones and
I think someone briefly touched on that
two but there is a lot of research
because I answered this question the way
he asked it correctly but it is
definitely true whether you it's just
from basic a jet lag or studies on
stress there is a significant uh amount
of research that shows that traveling
across time zones does create a
difficulty but that's not what this bill
does anyway but yes there is Def I
should have sent that research out and I
apologize
okay representative fellows
thank you madam chair I apologize for
raising my hand 20 times
um I something I noticed over the
weekend is I think there's a technical
issue and it has to do with when the
Things become effective
so the first thing that for anything to
Really Happen the first thing that has
to happen is section three the
contingency that the other states
adopted that that part's fine but then
it says after after three one and two
both become effective and section two is
when the state is going to ask
the U.S Department of Transportation if
we can make the change
and
that's what most States pass this also
says at the same time we're just going
to apply to have our time zone change
that we're actually going to change it
in State Statute that's what section one
does
thank you
representative
thank you madam chair I agree with Sally
sorry I kept raising my hand I'm glad
you fully mentioned because I didn't
know why it kept dropping off
I just wanted to point out that I
believe it was representative lakas said
that this wouldn't happen until New York
changed and I just want to point out New
York is not mentioned in the bill at all
it's just dependent on Maine and
Massachusetts
thank you
yes representative yeah the reason I
mentioned New York is that Although our
bill just mentions made in Massachusetts
there's a uh a similar Bill and you know
similar statute Massachusetts or maybe
it's uh in process that one mentions
um I don't know if it mentions but
mentions Connecticut and on maybe Rhode
Island and the Connecticut one
definitely mentions New York and so you
know New York would have to go first
then Connecticut could go then
Massachusetts then us so although it's
indirect ours does depend on New York
yes unless Massachusetts changes we're
Connecticut or Massachusetts yeah it's
but definitely we don't
this bill doesn't say we're going it
alone and I haven't heard anybody saying
we should be going it along
all right any other comments questions
thank you madam chair
I just for a little bit of clarification
uh the bills in Massachusetts and other
states
are those dealing with Atlantic time
zones or those dealing with just doing
away with
daylight savings and staying on the
Eastern Time Zone
the only know about things is
Massachusetts and the bill that they had
lot their last term was to go to
Atlantic time
the however they're in a new session and
I don't know what their current bill
says
thank you
I can address that
yes representative fellows thank you
madam chair
um the bill that Massachusetts had two
years ago it you could you I could go
into their system and see the bill but
it was never in probably the equivalent
of our introduced because if you try to
go into their system and find that bill
now the one from two years ago you will
not find it
yes thank you any other comments
right it's like most people have spoken
their piece the motion is ought to pass
made by representative Schultz and the
clerk of all the rules representative
Roy yes
clerk votes yes representative Pearsons
yes representative yakubovic yes
representative leicus yes representative
Allegro yes representative Bailey yes
yes
representative goalie no
representative show it no
representative Judy
nope
representative Schmidt yes
representative Schultz yes
representative fellows
no
representative no
yes representative Grodin
no
representative O'Brien yes
14 years five Nays
all right on the consent calendar
correct
if anyone wishes to write a Minority
um
it's about time
yes yes I I apologize I'm not sure if I
notified you before did you see my email
shortly before session
you're going to be me out for a dentist
right at one o'clock thank you no
troubles
I I don't think any of those any of the
bills are going to be that uh
[Music]
I'm not sure that's my hope and
obviously I made the appointment well
before we knew we'd be meeting on
okay uh it's almost noon I think we need
a break so thank you all for getting
a few things done and uh we'll be back
okay
are you on
foreign
your room is muted though so I you're I
cannot hear you
um
unless you unmute yourself or unmute the
room
while we're waiting I just want to say I
miss seeing you guys in person
especially you've rep scitec
we can wave to each other on Thursday
from across the fields
I don't know that I'm going
oh I qua I just
well I guess it's going to be on the
public thing and that's fine but
um my doctor said I'm definitely in in
the current group that's supposed to get
the coveted vaccine because I am that
ill
um unfortunately
uh and I don't get my first shot until
May
so while the risk may be is lower it's
not as low as it was last summer and I'm
scared that
I mean my doctor thinks that I would
definitely be someone who would be
likely to be hospitalized if I caught
covid so I probably not going and I feel
sad that
they haven't been able to figure out a
way for
people like me to participate I'm really
there's that man I unmuted the fitness's
hb170 yeah yeah that's the if you turn
the video on that would be great then we
representative Schultz
yes sir there's another way to get your
shot early and that's turned 65.
well I just want to stop bragging about
how how ill my doctor thinks I am at
first I was like Yay I can get it and
I'm like oh I qualify you know what I
mean
drastically uh
Pam are you there please yes I'm here
may I have a bouquet of Clerks forms
please
um I'll have Miriam send them to the
printer sure okay thank you
a little Whitman sampler of the will do
oh my gosh remember the witness Samplers
do they still have those of course they
do I'm not sure they were manufactured
by Neko confectionary New England
confectioners right well they have the
equivalents hold on they were at Mass
Avenue across from my yes
and I saw I saw that you may not have
heard of Candy covered but they also
made yes
pie bars which they had like size
flavors one was blue one was caulking
compound the other was linseed oil they
weren't very appealing uh but I used to
look out and the building got more and
more decrepit and then they moved to
Charlestown now it comes back as uh
Heritage or uh
uh Retro Candy every now and then I
don't know who makes it I distributed to
my class and tell them you can tell your
brain kids you actually had Neko wafers
oh my gosh that's right I
I grew up in Cambridge right near there
they also made the uh little Hots you
I like that they keep adding new sayings
and you're right on Route One yes I had
trouble reading my last candy hearts
someplace
uh can I just give you a quick note that
representative Cushing will not be
available to introduce the 1 30 or 2
o'clock bills he is in line for
I have uh representative Casey Conley
will introduce the one at 1 30.
and representative Lucy Weber will
introduce at two o'clock just
just wired me back
good
she's not
foreign
house bill 84.
and
yeah
I believe his his fan going to be
down
no
in that case I call unrepresentative
Conley who is the Prime sponsor you'll
foreign
hi there is everyone able to hear me
yes thank you okay sorry about that um
I am Casey Conway state representative
from uh well thank you madam chair and
committee members Casey Conway state
representative from
uh Dover representing Stratford County
District 13.
um here now to introduce HP 170
um this bill would call upon the
governor to issue a proclamation each
year commemorating the first
all women labor strike in the United
States this occurred in Dover in 1830
if adopted this bill would just be added
to the existing calendar of observances
proclaimed by the governor in a given
year as the committee likely knows uh
there are you know more than two dozen
of these and they include special days
weeks months
um other examples would include uh you
know gold star Mother's Day uh the first
Sunday after Easter Portsmouth peace
treaty day on September 5th maybe Lyme
disease prevention month and so on
um this bill is identical to when I
introduced last year that went through
the labor committee
um which recommended passage 20 to zero
and then it uh left the house via the
consent calendar before
covet arrived and kind of shut down the
legislative process
so real quick uh this is a little
background on the event in Dover
um
you know for those people who have been
to our city and I think the committee
has a couple members from our city
there's several Mills uh sort of
dominating our downtown one being a 735
foot long structure that runs the length
of our
uh main main drag
um it's home to Lofts and breweries now
but in the 1800s it was a site of a
lively textile mill
in those days women performed most of
the work in the Mills they worked looms
and weaving machines in the cloth making
process it was dangerous it was
unpleasant work and the pay was low even
by historical standards
um just before this uh turnout as they
called it back then the Mills owner cut
their wages by uh 10 to those days
amounted to a nickel so they made just
50 cents and they lost a nickel a day
don't Christmas or excuse me the day
after Christmas on 1830 half of the
Mills 800 plus uh Workforce walked out
uh the pay cut was the primary grievance
but they also were had concerns about
quotas and uh and safety and so on
um the newspaper account at the time did
not look fondly uh on this
um event and I'm just gonna quote from
Foster's Daily Democrat which still
exists
um
quote a general turnout of the girls
employed in the cotton factories in this
town to a number of six or eight hundred
took place on Friday last on account of
some imaginary grievance it has We
Believe turned out to their cost as well
as disgrace and since that time many
have returned to work in all who are
permitted will without doubt return in
the course of a few days the girls on
leaving the factory yard formed a
procession nearly half a mile in length
and marched through town with Marshall
Music accompanied by a roar of artillery
the hole presented one of the most
disgusting scenes ever witnessed
uh so that's the newspaper account it
did correctly predict that the workers
would return to the mill and they did uh
three days after the incident nearly all
were back there
workplace uh no better than before
but it was not uh by any means a total
you know a total loss it inspired uh
female Mill workers in Lowell and
elsewhere who had heard about what
happened in Dover uh and adjusted their
own approaches uh accordingly uh in a
similar walk out in Lowell was
successful
uh history has not forgotten this event
by any means but it is not widely known
in our state and it's not entirely
widely known even here in Dover
um
dover's former librarian Kathy beaudwin
was instrumental in collecting historic
details about this event but I certainly
think it's
worthwhile for our state and our city
and our region just um just for all of
us to sort of know a little bit more
about it
so with that I I asked the committee to
recommend passage and I'll certainly
attempt to answer any questions
thank you representative are there any
thank you very much
wait a second Peter Smith
well since I was uh referenced even
though that not named
um as one of the Dover representatives
and I remember that day very well
um
I thought the women all looked uh fine
and didn't think there was anything
disgraceful about it but seriously uh
the reality is that it was very
significant because For the First Time
In in this country a group of women
stood up I'm not sure there had been any
labor actions before uh this one but
certainly no none involving all women
they stood up for their own needs and
rights uh and and and and it turned out
as they called it then so uh
representative Conley
um what was the committee that heard it
last year voted 20 to nothing you say
um and was it and it was on the consent
calendar
uh and is it your opinion that it would
have uh passed the Senate as well had it
been able to go through the usual
legislative process
thank you
thank you representative
um
hesitate to predict what the other body
would do in any matter but I certainly
would hope given the the path it had in
the house and the lack of resistance
that they would have had a similar
response uh in that chamber
thank you what committee did it go to
representative Conley labor
yep thank you
all right seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you take
care
is there anyone else who wishes to
Madam chairman yes Ms van thanks uh I
would like to testify on this bill
please
uh as a person who taught New Hampshire
history for a number of years I used to
teach this turnout and it's hugely
important as a mark of people coming
together and working for better
conditions and the fact that so many of
them were young women who had left the
farms in order to work in the Mills with
the promise that they would be cared for
appropriately I I just think it's an
amazing story and I'd like to see us
adopt this day
thank you very much
okay thank you thank you for your
testimony
we're
Excuse Me Miss tentarelli
thank you very much for this opportunity
to speak in support of HB 170.
you know the mills in New Hampshire and
Massachusetts in the early 1800s
provided the first chance for large
numbers of young women to leave home and
earn their own livings but it also
provided the first opportunity for women
to band together and learn how to use
their civic voices
the 1828 strike didn't succeed getting
better pay and equal rights for the mill
girls in Dover but it did strengthen the
resolve of working women to speak up for
themselves
about 15 years later Sarah Bagley of
Candia was working in a mill in Lowell
when she organized and became president
of the first female labor union in the
country calling for improved working
conditions and a 10-hour work day
she testified in the Massachusetts
legislature all to also to no avail
but the game was in women learning to
speak up for themselves and others over
the next decades many women were active
in the abolition movement using their
civic voices for racial Justice
and of course following the Civil War
women around the country spoke up
demanding women's voting rights become
the law of the land
so the Dover Mill girls should be
appropriately commemorated as early
examples of women finding and using
their civic voices for themselves and
others for equality and human rights so
I urge you to support HB 170 and thank
you for this opportunity to speak
yes Mr tentarelli could you tell us who
you are and who you represented anyone
uh right now I'm representing myself I
am president of the League of Women
Voters which is a direct descendant
organization of the women's suffrage
movement and I'm also a presenter for
the New Hampshire Humanities on a
history of women's suffrage going around
the state via Zoom presenting a program
on that last year and this year so I
have researched a lot of this women's
history and and was very pleased to see
that right here in New Hampshire we had
some of the earliest female voices
speaking up for civic rights
thank you very much and thank you for
representative Conley you don't get to
ask ask questions I'm afraid
are there any questions from the
committee
seeing none
good afternoon honorable members of the
committee my name is Amanda Elizabeth
toll I represent Cheshire 16 which
encompasses the city of Keene at large I
am a co-sponsor of HB 170. when we
remember and teach the history of
ordinary and marginalized groups we
encourage the idea that folks of all
backgrounds can play a role in shaping
history
women's history is important labor
history is important and how
marginalized folks have helped create a
more just and Equitable New Hampshire is
also important that's why I'm
co-sponsoring this bill
I urge you to support HB 170. thank you
to representative Casey Conley for
bringing this forward I will not be
taking questions
right okay is there anyone else who
uh
representative
already said so all right thank you all
and I'm closing the hearing on House
Field 170.
and opening the hearing on House Bill
and representative van
thank you chairman thank you to the
committee I am here to introduce this
bill seeking to place granity's birthday
in January on the calendar in honor of
her long work for democracy in the
United States as you all know she uh her
most famous story of course is that she
walked across the United States ending
up in Washington in order to draw
attention to the issues of campaign
Finance reform
she was at that time in her 90s I
actually knew granny D quite briefly I
was a nursery school teacher and her
daughter-in-law's nursery school and I
used to sometimes see Granny D in the
kitchen she was an amazing indomitable
woman and I very much hope that the
committee will
move this forward again as with the mill
girls it was a bill that was put forward
last year and was lost to the pandemic
so I would be delighted to see Granny D
honored as she should be another
indomitable New Hampshire woman
thank you very much
I representative Schultz
representative van would you believe I
first met granny D before I'd even been
to New Hampshire when she walked through
America in Arkansas
there you go yes she walked all the way
across she had people walking with her
it was an amazing thing to do I am 65. I
am just in awe of the idea that she
cared so deeply about our democracy that
she did this thing in her in her very
old age
a follow-up question Madam chair
follow up
uh isn't it true that she had broad
bipartisan support for her cause she did
indeed there was wide understanding that
um unless the wave
um
campaigns or financed is clear and uh
open that it's very hard to know who's
thank you
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair I'm wanting uh
Representatives whether uh there were
any recordings made of her speeches I
had an opportunity to hear who speak in
person after her return from her and
fabulous walk across the country and she
was a remarkable auditor do you know if
there are any recordings of any of her
speeches I believe that there are
um I do not have any but I believe that
I was there for her 100th birthday in
the council chambers uh she uh she not
only made that walk but she survived it
and to run for a senate as well
thank you representative Dan
thank you madam chair is anyone else
excuse me Madam chair I thought there
were several people who were signed up
to speak uh Brian Beale from Alton Bay
perhaps and I read three names listed
that are raising their hands
I
okay
he's been promoted he needs to mute him
there hello
good afternoon
thank you madam chair may I have uh
roughly four or five minutes
I would
less would probably be better but please
introduce yourself and start my name is
Dennis Burke I'm calling from Phoenix
Arizona uh I'd like to add the
perspective of thousands of people
outside of New Hampshire who continue to
take instruction and inspiration from
granny D's work she walked through many
States including Arizona made friends in
all of them even Texas where in fact
Ross Perot gave her his private number
and said call whatever she needed it
absolutely anything she said thank you
very much but reminded him that she was
walking to protest not Embrace big money
in politics but she added that having a
billionaire offer unlimited resources
was something everyone should experience
at least once
Ross took no offense he invited her to
speak at the reform party's National
Convention where she brought down the
house and said no to a floor nomination
as their vice presidential candidate
which was not bad for a Democrat from
New Hampshire but the reason for that
was the subject of her remarks of her
walk and really of her life was the
nonpartisan defense of human scale
democracy where we all participate as
equals her commitment to the human scale
goes back to her work to protect an
Inuit commit a community in Alaska from
unnecessary nuclear testing in the 1950s
she and her husband Jim senior were
successful in that and maintained
lifelong friendships with the people of
that Village when she learned of the
terrible poverty in here in Arizona on
the native reservations she learned that
much of their money came from making
rugs and selling them so she started
making rugs and selling them and sending
all the money to the reservations and
also supported the the the tribes with
work in Congress
what she learned in those efforts in
those years was that her members of
Congress were open to her arguments and
later when she returned to those offices
to seek help in reading campaigns of
clearly corrupt uh donations she was
rebuffed and she was a citizen scorned
at that point at age 90 her real work in
life began as a messenger of democracy
and her message really was a product of
New Hampshire town halls and it struck a
chord across the U.S and across the
world reporters in fact came to walk
with her from the UK from Germany
Scandinavia and Japan in fact her little
book of speeches
sells as much today in those countries
as it does here she walked 3 200 miles
despite a bad back emphysema and a
terrible set of leg cramps every every
evening when she stopped walking she
climbed mountain ranges during blizzards
and when snow closed the roads into
Washington she crossed country skied the
last 180 miles of her epic journey into
Washington she got her bill passed over
Mitch McConnell's objection he had said
that campaign reform would pass when
hell freeze is over and she said take a
picture of me on these skis and send it
to Mitch which happened uh at age uh 93
she traveled the country to register
working women to vote sometimes by
taking over their jobs long enough for
them to register and some of those jobs
included feeding alligators in an
alligator park
um being a mermaid at a mermaid Park a
tending bar in the French Quarter of New
Orleans uh and and all of that she was
bringing attention to a voter
registration uh efforts in in those
States when she crossed Arizona we were
working on a re on reforms to end the
most egregious kinds of gerrymandering
she reminded people of both parties the
demographics are changing and both
parties have a stake in the creation of
a fair system it passed handily as a
ballot initiative and we enjoy it today
in her mid and late 90s she traveled and
walked across any state that was
considering new approaches to democratic
fairness and many of them passed and the
late spring of 2004 when it suddenly
looked like Senator Greg would run
unopposed she ran for the U.S Senate
knowing she had no chance of winning but
that it would be a chance to walk across
the state two or three times and make
100 speeches about democracy and fair
elections which is what she did uh I
think she is whom you might want your
grandchildren to know about remember as
they craft their own long free
productive and joyful lives we carry
forward important messages for the Next
Generation with statues of bronze or
marble but sometimes just with words
enshrined in law like like the bill
before you now it is cheaper to do it
the way you have in front of you then
with bronze or marble which is very New
Hampshire and very Doris you would have
hated to pay more taxes even for her own
statue
the granite States Old Man of the
Mountain collapsed in 2003 she outlasted
him by seven years she is the iconic
figure of the Granite State now and she
represents the tough love of democracy
that needs to be cherished and
remembered now more than ever
thank you very much for hearing me out
thank you are there any questions for Mr
Burke
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank
good afternoon
um Dan weeks from Nashua New Hampshire I
really appreciate this opportunity to
testify briefly I'm not on top of a
building but for my day job I work in
solar energy and this is a recent
installation in Londonderry
um but I'm grateful for the chance to
just give a quick personal perspective
on on why I strongly support this bill
and hope that you will as well I grew up
in the Monadnock area of New Hampshire
in Temple I went to conval high school
and when I was 17 as an unsuspecting
teenager I had the chance to hear granny
D give one of her first speeches on
returning from that cross-country walk
in the year 2000 when she spoke at
conval which was the district where she
herself was from in Dublin and it lit a
fire under me
um and and a lot of my peers as well it
was part of my becoming an active
citizen concerning myself about the
issue of democracy and integrity in our
elections set me on a path that has in
many ways defined my life ever since I
feel very privileged to after going away
from New Hampshire for Americorps and
for college to be back here raising my
three young kids and and making a life
here for my family as a as an active
Citizen and I do really take inspiration
from granny D for that I was privileged
for several years to lead the non-profit
nonpartisan organization open democracy
which he founded which continues to work
for campaign Finance reform and I
believe you will hear from some of the
current staff of open democracy as well
today and to to be able to continue her
work which was always honored by people
across the aisle John McCain was a a big
fan of hers for instance Senator Russ
Feingold as well New Hampshire's late
Senator Warren Rudman as well she really
worked hard to find common ground with
people across the Spectrum in addressing
what she felt was a a answer on our
system the role of big money from all
sorts of interests across the political
spectrum that was dampening the voice of
ordinary citizens in politics so I feel
personally indebted to her for helping
me find my life's Mission my voice in
civic affairs and I know that whenever
other people encounter her story she has
a tremendous ability to inspire them as
well so I hope that you will take this
simple step of making sure that that her
name lives on in New Hampshire and that
more young high school kids like me can
can get acquainted with that inspiring
story and can also find their way into
public service one way or another thank
you so much
thank you Mr weeks are there any
questions from the committee
thank you for your testimony
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the executive departments and
administrations committee for the record
my name is Olivia Zink I'm the executive
director of open democracy action a
nonpartisan non-profit organization with
35 000 members we're a pro voter
organization working to fix democracy
campaign Finance reform redistricting
and promote honest elections and Granny
D was our founder I'm here to speak in
favor of house bill 204.
throughout her entire life was dedicated
to service in her 90th year she took the
national Spotlight with her 3 200 mile
we asked the house and the Senate to
come together to honor this woman who 20
years ago saw this important crisis of
our time this crisis of democracy
last year the New Hampshire Senate voted
24-nothing to support Senate bill 530
but 24 nothing to support Senate Bill
537 but due to covid it was laid on the
table in the house USA Today did a story
of Granite State women who have
demonstrated strength courage and
resolve both before and after uh the
legitimate right to vote and these
Yankee independent personas and rugged
resilience and Granny D made this list
um I first met granny D in the basement
of a uu Church
she inspired me so much I was working on
groundwater and access to clean unsafe
drinking water and she told me that our
fight for water is also a fight for
democracy I will never forget her wise
word
she also talked about how the power of
one if you see something that's wrong
speak up to make a difference
I was had the pleasure to write the
forward of this book called the politics
of Joy
um which is a book of her fearless walks
and historic talks and Granny G
um
in in that forward I put we find
ourselves living in extraordinary crisis
in our democracy
also New Hampshire magazine wrote she
with her own feathered hat which I have
behind me
um
Wise Women politics in the Lake of the
late granny d
um and she also he also in New Hampshire
magazine they talked about how she
managed to get Bill Bill Clinton and
Newt Gingrich while they were
campaigning in New Hampshire
um to agree that campaign Finance was
was important and so this is one example
of how she inspired both sides of of the
aisle a more personal example to me is
my Republican grandmother read her book
granny D you're never too old to raise a
little
um h e double hockey sticks and um my my
Republican grandmother wanted to meet
Doris haddock and I had the pleasure to
take her
um to hear Doris speak
um and I think these are examples of of
inspiration from both sides of the aisle
also Governor sununu has issued a
proclamation honoring granny D-Day
um and I in my testimony linked to the
honoring Doris granny D haddock beloved
by voters of all Stripes it would be a
good way
to
to divide
to bridge the gap on our divided
politics and repair our Republic thank
you for voting ought to pass I do want
to also mention from a question that was
asked earlier if you go to grannyd.org
you can see many videos of Doris
speaking and there's also a documentary
done by HBO that my colleague Brian
Beale has emailed to you as well so if
you're interested in a 30-minute
documentary of her that is also
available
and with that I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you very much representative
Schmidt has a question
thank you very much Madam chair and
thank you for being here Olivia because
I was about to ask you whether there are
in fact any recordings of her speaking
uh and would you please if you haven't
done it already would you please send
the committee uh the link that you
reference in your remarks because uh
having heard her speak uh in in
Manchester on Elm Street uh uh in person
um to a Full House and seeing what a
galvanizing speaker she was I know that
my colleagues of both parties uh would
be interested in having access to to her
remarks and uh and to see what a truly
remarkable speaker she was so could you
do that for us I would be happy to email
you the link but it's also very easy to
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 204
you know I thought about that for about
two minutes before the camera went on
and I blew it so Bob Perry uh Stratford
and I'll begin my presentation by uh
saying once again now that you can hear
me
um that there have been some wonderful
presentations here today uh involving
Doris haddock
I met her when I did my stint on the
election law committee a wonderful
person and
Dennis Brooks account was just terrific
I'll begin my presentation
Madam chair and members of the committee
Doris Haddix 3200 mile walk across the
country were prompted by her reading of
an amendment and a bill to provide the
tobacco industry with a 50 million
dollar tax credit
whoa now we have always had money in
politics she said but never like this
that's what started it yeah end quote
she was sure she was losing
our democracy we were losing our
democracy
though her walk was challenged by a
multitude of physical dangers heat cold
dry dust rain snow wild animals
unpredictable human behaviors
the biggest challenge was getting in the
way of the money machine that influences
our elections and the few and Powerful
who not only control those machines but
disproportionately influence our
elections through their corporate packs
super Pacs and as individuals
akin to the current LLC loophole
but in 2002 her bravery paid off with
the bipartisan campaign Finance Reform
Act also named known as McCain Feingold
signed into law by President George W
bush
in a challenge to the law brought in
2003 the court largely upheld McCain
Feingold only to have the law largely
obliterated in 2010
by citizens united v f e c
Doris died 50 days after that ruling
in the 2020 in the 2010 Federal
elections the top contributors were a
husband and wife that's seven million
606 thousand dollars at the bottom of
the list of 100 was another husband and
wife at 266 900 dollars
but by 2020 the top contributor was a
husband and wife at 218
million
179 thousand dollars plus excuse me
representative Perry could you
concentrate on the bill and on granny D
um Madam chair I'm trying to form the
basis uh draw a contrast between uh what
it was like when Granny D walked across
the country to what it is now and the
importance then
exemplified by the importance of it now
again but by 2020 the top contributor
was a husband and wife at 218 million
I've said that and number 100
contributed 3 million two hundred sixty
eight thousand dollars
by January 2021 total political spending
became a 14.4 billion dollar industry
some contributors both corporate and
individual are claiming buyer's remorse
temporarily cutting off donations some
are asking that their contributions be
returned the list of disgruntled include
the Marriotts Hallmark Best Buy Amazon
Dell Dow Chemical a t the Walt Disney
Company more and all corporate Giants
the list of companies temporarily
terminating contributions include
Facebook BP Goldman Sachs JPMorgan Chase
Citigroup Raytheon more at all corporate
Giants
does the 25 contribution even matter
anymore
there are a few people we meet in life
who display the courage and conviction
of Doris granny D haddock a frail and
unhealthy person who walked 3 200 miles
across the country live to tell about it
and inspired Congress to act consistent
with mutual concerns about money and
politics
she deserves her rightful place on the
honor roll of exemplary American
citizens
I urge passage of this bill
are there questions for representative
Perry
seeing none thank you for your testimony
representative Horrigan
thank you very much Madam chair uh I um
I choose one of many thousands of people
who got to know Granny D and um
it doesn't and I actually I think I
still have her uh her one of her yard
signs in my garage in case she ever runs
again because it doesn't really
doesn't really feel like she's dead
she's still very much of a living
presence uh very much of living presence
I think for everybody who got to know
her and in fact uh when she passed in
2010 shortly after her uh 100th birthday
party the executive Council chamber just
sort of
didn't feel like she was going away just
that her work was entering a different
phase and
I'm not a big believer in ghosts but uh
people who do believe gotev said that
she's been seen in the gallery keeping
an eye on us back when we're still
reading in reptile uh and they're still
but uh so the gallery was still open but
uh yeah and um
and the uh other thing is even though
her life was much longer than uh most of
us get it was still short too short and
I remember at her birthday party uh she
was introduced by a uh young woman who
was uh
school-aged young school age girls was
probably uh not much older than Grande D
was when women got the right to vote and
so like you know they're they're live
you know there was the two of them
together
he's a council chamber so that really
told me how little time you know how
short life is and how really it was not
a long time ago that women weren't
allowed to vote so um
so she was a woman remarkable woman who
made a big difference she's continued to
make a big difference and I certainly uh
I don't think we should observe her uh
on granny D-Day and we should probably
remember her every day so that's some
that's that's about all I have to say
about it so I hope you'll vote for this
bill I'd be happy to answer any
questions if you'd like
thank you representative Oregon
are there any questions
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
team num I'll close the hearing on House
Bill 204 and open the hearing on House
Bill 273 I believe representative Conley
foreign
chair committee members Casey Conway
state representative from Dover
representing Stratford County District
13.
um here now to introduce HB 273 uh pinch
hitting for the prime sponsor
um
on relative short notice so I'll do my
best here
um this uh is is a simple
straightforward Bill uh in line with the
uh proposals the committee has heard uh
over the last half hour or so uh this
would establish May 13th as
um youth franchise and youth office
holder day in New Hampshire honoring the
50th anniversary of New Hampshire
ratifying the 26th amendment it occurred
on that day May 13 1971 and that of
course uh granted the right to vote to
folks age 18 to 21 who uh previously
um
you know the the voting age was 21.
and some quick research uh it this uh
was sort of a unique moment in our
nation's history
um Congress uh had had lowered the
voting age to 18
um in 1970 through the Voting Rights Act
um it was then contested I went to the
Supreme Court which determined that that
lowered age established uh by Congress
applied only to Federal elections a
constitutional amendment was uh drafted
um and in record time uh it it was
enacted and took effect July 1 1971. so
uh certainly an important event
um in our nation uh New Hampshire of
course had a role through its
ratification
um so I would ask the committee to
please consider uh pass a recommending
passage and finally uh Madam chair and
committee I did want to uh Circle back I
misspoke on HP 170 the date was 1828 as
another uh person correctly indicated in
her testimony and that was why I raised
my hand I was wanting to correct that
and I'm sorry for that uh embarrassing
uh mistake but with that I'm happy to
take questions now on 273 HP 273 if
um representative Pearson
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative Conley for taking my
question this is a one-time
um event to commemorate anniversary did
you reach out to the governor's office
to for a proclamation on a one-time
event
which is the kind of the typical route
we go with those
uh rep thank you representative for the
question uh
you know I I am not sure who the prime
sponsor has reached out to uh in terms
of uh trying to make that happen
definitely seems like something uh
that would be um one option another
option is is the bill we have before us
so
um
it's not the prime sponsor so yeah
other questions
thank you very much
representative Conley uh I'm wondering
were 18 year olds required to register
for the selective service act under the
selective service act for the draft at
uh at that age
uh representative Schmidt I can answer
that yes
oh thank you very much Madam chair
because uh uh I know at the time it was
pointed out that uh that uh the young
people young men anyway at that age uh
could be called into service and killed
in the service of their country but they
couldn't vote so seemed like a good idea
to me to be allowing them to to vote
appreciate your information
representative fellows
thank you madam chair
hearing it representative Conley might
happen to know
the date that the Constitutional
Amendment became effective this is the
date that New Hampshire ratified but
when
when it became effective thank you
representative I do thanks to uh
a nice website that Congress had put
together on this amendment uh it took
effect nationally or excuse me the
ratification was July 1 1971 uh the
Nixon Administration certified it four
days later on July 5th 1971.
thank you
how nice to know
is there any other questions for
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you to the committee
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
that case I will close the hearing on
and also the hearing on House Bill 283
[Music]
Madam chair I'm texting with her right
perhaps you will introduce the bill and
we will hear from her when she gets here
for I am honored to introduce
um
HB and I'm blanking
HB 283 proclaiming April 11th as
and hopefully representative De Lorenzo
well in that case I'll call uh on loose
temporelli
again while representative D Lorenzo is
sorry I was fumbling to unmute there
um this is not my area of expertise but
when I saw this string of bills
I had to look up Mr wentwill and uh so I
just will fill in the Gap a bit here
while you're waiting for the sponsor
I've forgotten which town Mr wetwell was
from he was of mixed race in the 1700s
he served in the Revolutionary War
um and then he became what they think is
probably the first black elected
official
certainly in New Hampshire possibly even
in the country
so I'm hoping that your sponsor gets on
and can fill in those gaps
um but it is yet another interesting
story from New Hampshire's history I'm
so glad we're so full of Firsts here and
that's about all I have to say here so I
will let you wait for the sponsor to
yes
Madam chair okay please introduce
yourself and talk to us great uh I can
fill everybody in uh hello Madam Sharon
committee members my name is John Herman
I live in Newmarket New Hampshire I am
representing myself but I serve on the
board for the new market Historical
Society I'm a local school teacher a
husband and father of two children and I
am enthusiastically in support of HP
283. I have spent years researching
Wentworth cheswell's life and deeds and
recently I've been focused on spreading
the word about him in anticipation of
his 275th birthday
there's a four page uh feature published
in New Hampshire magazine today if you
want to run out and grab a copy uh as
someone who has held his 250 year old
journal and transcribed many of his
fragile personal legal documents I can
say that the one thing you should take
away from his life is his astonishing
dedication to public service in the
defense of Liberty Wentworth cheswell
experience Liberty in a way that many of
his peers did not his father hope still
was a house right who as one
contemporary from Portsmouth noted was
unable to attend a housewarming party
for a house he himself had built unless
personally and publicly invited by the
homeowner this was due to the color of
his skin yet his son Wentworth grandson
of a slave Rose to be one of the most
prosperous and influential individuals
in his community
raised in a community known at the time
for its trade with the West Indies which
included the trade of sugar and slaves
Wentworth cheswell became what George
Mason University determined to be the
first African-American elected to public
office in the history of the United
States
but that's just the start of Wentworth
cheswell's story like Paul Revere he
wrote as a messenger for the committee
of safety he served as a soldier in John
langdon's company of light horse
volunteers which made the 250 mile march
to Saratoga New York to join the
Continental Army in defeating the
British the Battle of Saratoga the first
major American victory for the
revolution
Wentworth cheswell served as a constable
school teacher inaugural School member
selectman Town moderator assessor
justice of the peace for the county he
was even the coroner
in fact he served every year of his
adult life but one
and there are some who note that that
last that lost year of service uh
conspicuously coincides with the year of
the ratification of the U.S Constitution
so I like to believe he's lent some
effort to that cause
uh Wentworth cheswell was also a
pioneering archaeologist his research
informed Jeremy belnap's first volumes
of New Hampshire history
and cheswell was not only in early New
Hampshire archaeologist he's arguably
one of the earliest in the nation
passionate about history and scholarly
Pursuits he donated books and funds to
establish his community's first Library
he was also the parent to 13 children so
uh I'm very inspired by him and it is my
honor to speak before you in support of
HB 283 thank you
thank you very much are there questions
looks like you you uh all our questions
no representative fellows has a question
thank you ma'am chair I'm just wondering
if there are any books published about
him
I'm just getting warmed up but uh I do
there he's been a part of scholarly like
thesis documents
um but there is no book that is focused
entirely on him um I'm working with a
children's illustrator right now to
develop a book uh aimed at children
um
there's time
is there uh
this is representative D Lorenzo I am
ready to join you excellent please uh
introduce yourself and tell and tell us
about this Bill thank you so much and
please indulge me I was in the wrong
place at the wrong time so Madam chair
and honorable members of this committee
thank you for hearing my testimony today
my name is representative Charlotte
dilorenzo I represent the towns of
Newmarket and new fields in Rockingham
County I've been a resident of Newmarket
since 1993. as soon as I moved here I
registered to vote and got a library
card at the new market Public Library
democracy and literacy are high on the
list of carriage values passed on to me
by my parents and my grandparents it was
in 2002 that I first learned that
Wentworth jeswell a black man was a
revolutionary war veteran a new market
Town father and helped establish the
town's first Free Library
Mr chesswell was a hidden figure until
2002 when Mr Richard Alburn a new market
resident shared his research on
Wentworth chesswell in local newspapers
I've been inspired by Mr chesswell's
accomplishments and contributions in
2020 a group of Newmarket residents
joined together to establish the
Wentworth Jess will appreciation society
April 11 2021 marks the 175th
anniversary of Wentworth Castle's birth
and our town is stepping up to get this
Noble Patriot his deserving place in
town history and in New Hampshire
history that is why I sponsor this bill
with that I will step aside for those
who wish to speak thank you madam chair
and honorable members of this committee
thank you very much are the questions
good afternoon again members of the
committee thank you madam chair for the
opportunity to testify on a second bill
and if I may um in order to save your
time I wish to testify in support of
both this HP 283 and rather than
appearing again
um a little bit later also in support of
HP 84 and 155 but just briefly if I may
again a personal perspective
um as as noted previously I grew up in
New Hampshire and proud to trace my
family lineage back 12 generations to
the first generation of Europeans who
arrived in Portsmouth Harbor and made
their home in the New Hampshire Seacoast
not far from Wentworth she as well and I
grew up I'm proud of that European
Heritage in totally unaware of our more
diverse Heritage as a state I'm totally
unaware of the fact that several hundred
or even a few thousand people of African
descent were enslaved in New Hampshire
up until the 1840s
um which speaks to
um the next bill up um to honor Ona
judge who escaped enslavement from the
Washington presidential household in
Philadelphia and settled in New
Hampshire where she lived for decades
also in the Seacoast and so um for me
just discovering in recent times this
history the inspiring story of Wentworth
cheswell also of own a judge and the
many others again hundreds of people who
were at one point enslaved in New
Hampshire and thousands of people of
African descent as well as of course the
many thousands of indigenous people who
occupied these lands before my ancestors
arrived it has been expanding my Horizon
and frankly has been inspiring to me and
is Meaningful to my family as well
although I traced back 12 generations of
European Heritage I'm fortunate to be
the dad of three young children who are
also of African descent my wife
emigrated to the U.S from South Africa
we met in graduate school abroad and so
as I think of wanting my kids to make
New Hampshire their home to make a
future here we know that the out
migration of young people is a challenge
it's one that my business faces where
we're always struggling to hire the
talent we need to work in the trades in
particular in clean energy I believe
that telling more of New Hampshire's
authentic history that just hasn't been
told so far by honoring characters like
Wentworth cheswell a remarkable
achievement that New Hampshire can claim
the first elected official of African
descent and also the remarkable story of
Ona judge as I know you'll consider in a
few more minutes who again made a life
for herself after escaping enslavement
as a young woman in the presidential
House in Philadelphia I think these
kinds of stories can be exciting can
fire the imaginations of all our
children personally my my three children
who I hope will see a home for
themselves helps and see people who can
be their role models and inspiration to
them who share their skin complexion but
also kids like me who just grow up
unawares but are excited to get to know
more of the world in our own history so
I think again as a proud granted Stater
I'm so grateful that this committee is
is spending time and that the lead
sponsors have introduced this
legislation these multiple bills and I
think this is a very exciting
opportunity for our state to tell a a
fuller history and again show that we
are indeed welcoming of all those who
have made us who we are and those who
will make us who we will become in the
years ahead so thanks again and I urge
you to support this bill as well as HP
84 and HP 155 thank you
thank you very much
is there anyone else
thank you madam chair I would just like
to keep my comment brief my name is
Tristan McLean I am speaking on behalf
of myself as a member of the public I
currently reside in Plymouth New
Hampshire
I think and
the steps involved and remedying and
reconciling with our country's past it's
only just that we recognize everyone
despite what the past has done for Mr
Wentworth
um
it would be nice to
kind of get to a better step of no
longer whitewashing history and I think
the Merit of wentworth's character
speaks much of our values that are much
in line with what we aspire to have in
our country
thank you very much
thank you Mr McLean
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
don't see anybody so
I will close the public hearing on House
Bill 283 open the hearing
thank you
thank you very much Madam chair
um watching all the graphics going on
about being admitted and and thank you
for allowing people to testify uh sort
of in person as it were
um I am here I am Lucy Weber I represent
the Connecticut River towns of Walpole
Westmoreland Chesterfield and Hinsdale
and I'm here today on behalf of
Representative Renee Cushing who is the
Prime sponsor to introduce House Bill 84
declaring May 21st is owner only judge
day and naming the new terminal at
Portsmouth International Airport at peas
in her honor
um
only judge was a house an enslaved house
servant in the household of George
Washington and as as some of the people
have testified in in earlier hearings
are our country's history is much more
uh
varied and interesting than what I was
taught in elementary school I grew up in
New York I was taught that I was from
the north and I had nothing to do with
any of the problems that have to do with
slavery or race
and it wasn't until when I was an adult
and I started doing genealogical
research that I realized that my very
own Quaker ancestors of all people had
enslaved
workers and
I was horrified and I think it's really
important for us to recognize
all of the aspects of our history as as
the young gentleman who testified just
before me said
in this case
um
this was the only enslaved person who
escaped from
the ownership of the Washington family
she lived with them both in Virginia and
in Philadelphia and I believe it was
from Philadelphia that she escaped and
came North to Portsmouth and she lived
in Portsmouth and in Greenfield and and
made the rest of her life there
Washington's made
pretty significant efforts to have her
return to them
and I think we need to know that and
understand that and celebrate the life
that she made for herself and understand
the lives of all those living in
colonial times but um you know I'm I'm
well aware that here in in Walpole there
were slaves
who were brought from Africa and then
brought to Walpole and and lived the
rest of their lives here and we need to
be telling their stories as well as the
stories that most of us who are white
grew up with
so with that I am going to ask that you
procla
um
uh that that house bill 84 biot to pass
and I will pass on to others who perhaps
know more about it the story than I do
but it's a fascinating story I have read
the book but I didn't have time to look
it out and review it for today so thank
you very much for the Indulgence
thank you very much who else is
I have a question
representative Schmidt representative
Weber will you take a question certainly
are you aware of the copy that I believe
the Portsmouth library has in its rare
books collection telling the story of
only judge
um at her first cape
and the first fight
to maintain her Freedom uh when when the
Washington family was making
considerable efforts to retrieve her and
know that there is is a book published
that I read with great interest some
time back and if only I still retained
as many brain cells as you do
representative Schmidt I would have been
able to address the issue better but I
thank you for the knowledge
I doubt I have more than you do
we can't find anyone else who signed up
to speak on this bill so if there is is
someone who wishes to speech please
representative Delorenzo you need to
here we go thank you madam chair
um you know I've read I read the story
of Oni judge and I was really impressed
and it's a it's a local story it's a
good story it's a story about a woman
who managed to get on a boat from um
Britannia and come up to Portsmouth and
made a life first for herself and her
family
um and I think it's only fitting that we
honor her memory her perseverance
and one of the nice things about the
bill is that it asks to name the new
terminal at peace after owner judge and
to me that's slightly ironic uh that
first of all this bill is being heard on
Washington's birthday and miss judge
escaped front of Washington and secondly
it's kind of ironic too that we want to
name an airport terminal after misjudged
because she was definitely a traveler
she traveled by herself from Portsmouth
from I mean sorry from Virginia to
Portsmouth and now we want to put her
name on an air terminal to show her
ability to not fly but to manage to get
from one place to the other thank you
madam chair
all right thank you representative are
there uh any questions from the
committee
representative fellows
yes thank you madam chair
um representative dilorenzo I'm just
wondering if you can share any
information with us about the part that
has to do with
um
naming the Air Terminal
and if we have any it's it's States in
section three that the P's Development
Authority would would pay the needs to
approve the sign and pay for the cost of
the sign and I'm just wondering if if
you spoke with people from your terminal
in
in got support from them or I have not
um I don't know if representative
Cushing has but um I can't answer that
representative Schmidt
[Music]
uh I had lowered my hand but I will I
will say as chairman of the Stratford
County delegation uh which is uh the
nominator for one of the members of the
peas Development Authority board uh that
I was certainly uh inquire of our
representative as to what their position
thank you representative Schmidt for
so
let's see
Mr Thomas I mute yourself
that case asthma elleny
thank you so much Madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
usmani
um I just wanted to say my strong
support of such a bill I'm a mother of
uh eight boys
um for uh black boys and I think it's
really important that our black children
our black community members see their
Heroes Our Heroes our state Heroes
recognize the way many others are
because it it really does affect
children it affects people when they
don't see people like themselves
recognized and so I think this is one
way New Hampshire can show it's going to
do good by its community and so I highly
recommend
thank you very much are there questions
thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else who wishes to
okay
all right Mr weeks
hello I'm Dan weeks again from Nashua
I'm just a final point of clarification
I appreciated the opportunity a few
minutes ago to to testify and support
um and I apologize there's some young
kids in the background
um simply to point out
um that miss judge actually went by the
name Ona judge Staines which was her
last name others have alluded to the
historical book completed by a professor
of History
titled never caught which provides a
detailed account of her life and she did
after settling in Portsmouth after
making her Escape Mary the gentleman
whose last name was stains and took his
name in the Oni nickname is one that she
was given as a diminutive when she was
enslaved but not one that she ever chose
to use herself so I don't know whether
this should be referred to the prime
sponsor representative Cushing or if the
committee would consider such an
amendment but the name by which
I apologize she knew herself was again
Ona judge Staines
s-t-a-i-n-e-s and I can recommend that
title as well as the work that the black
Heritage Trail of New Hampshire has done
I'm not a member but I'm just an
interested citizen who follows their
work so I do encourage the committee to
consider certainly to pass the bill I
hope but to do so I'm using the name
again by which she knew herself thank
you so much and I do apologize for the
noise
thank you very much for that information
Mr whips
can can I just can he just repeat her
name again
owner judge
slain stains that was
s-t-a-i-n-e-s I thought you were saying
that oh she didn't like to use Ona
Udi
[Music]
like the nickname
I get thank you thank you manage here
all right
see none
close the hearing
and open the hearing on House Bill 155
appear to have he appears to have his
hand raised Madam chair so maybe he's
having a technical problem there I am
thank you please uh
signing on to speak to an earlier Bill
anyway I'm president Timothy Horrigan I
represent uh African County District Six
the towns of Durham and Madbury and it's
actually not coincidental that I've
represented Durham um I
I took on this issue um I picked up the
Baton from former representative Wayne
Burton who's still a town counselor and
then he interned uh spearheaded an
effort to have an official indigenous
people's day uh celebration in Durham
and we've also uh
worshiper School District was also one
of the first school districts to
officially uh celebrate indigenous
people stay on October on the Monday in
October which is uh known by others as
Columbus Day so that's uh
that's how I how I came to be working on
this issue um it's a HP one to 55 it's a
very simple build even though there's a
lot of complicated issues behind it it's
simply changes the name of the existing
mid-october holiday
um held on the second Monday in October
from Columbus Day
prodigious peoples today
this Monday has been celebrated
unofficially and even officially as as
in Durham and the oysterville school
district as indigenous people say for
many years in fact it's become a more
significant
celebration then Columbus Day and then
we'll be continuing to be highlighted
the yearly calendar regardless of what
happens to HB 155 since um you know we
don't need nobody needs official uh
permission to you know celebrate a
holiday it's just uh you know
so I'm speaking just for myself as a
prime sponsor although I've I've good
reason to believe I'm far from alone
I've heard this from other supporters of
bills Mike Michael here
is a rename the official mid-october
holiday period I wanted to continue
having an official holiday in the second
Monday in October but uh I think it
should be officially named after the
native peoples of North America and I
very specifically wanted to not be named
after Christopher Columbus
um that's that's the goal um
I know there's an amendment floating
around by a member who hasn't spoken yet
and isn't even a member of the committee
who had some other day in mind um
actually if you want to have an
observation like granny D-Day or the
other days that I proposed earlier that
I actually don't object to that but I
don't want official holiday that's the
goal this bill is to have a mid-october
holiday on the second Monday in October
be in business people's day so that's
anyway Christopher Columbus as we all
learned in grade school is a man who
supposedly discovered American 1492.
and occurs to millions of people who are
already living in the Americas in 1492
were already well aware that America
existed they knew they were there
Columbus himself um
get a lot of theories about uh
navigation and geography of the Earth
but he he had some of these assumptions
were wrong but he had a very accurate
idea of how wide the Atlantic Ocean was
some he found land actually exactly
where he thought he was going to find it
um
and uh and one of the reasons where he
got though he was certainly not and he
was certainly not the uh first European
to travel to North America named the
best known example and actually we have
an observation with an observation many
years of Leif Erickson day but that's uh
but they need the best exams
Scandinavians established a very well
documented colony in Greenland would
survive for 500 years beginning in the
mid-19 900s um it's uh it is relatively
peacefully not long before Columbus's
time when The Descendants original
colonists migrated back to Scandinavia
in the mid 1400s and actually Greenland
is still part of continuing with Denmark
but then they were they were not the so
those Scandinavians were not the only
Europeans who traveled to North America
there's there's other cases and um
Columbus Day didn't become an official
federal holiday until 1971.
um
I think even in 1971 the main reason for
it was uh
as a that was shortly after the when we
were when we just landed on the moon it
was mostly holiday to celebrate
exploration in general and then uh
and uh the Columbus anyway and since
then uh historians have gained a clear
understanding of Columbus and it's now
cleared his journeys for one of the
great tragedies in human history even
though
even though it's probably inevitable
that uh you know
the the Americas and the rest of the
world lived like uh coming to closer
contact maybe in the past but it was it
was just a tragic history he uh
brilliant man in many ways but he was
also like did a lot of very very bad
things um
and then also Columbus never visited
what is now known as the United States
of America the closest he came to United
States was the Bahamas in Cuba
and for what it was he was not really
Italian
um he was from the Republic of Genoa
which is a small country that doesn't
exist anymore his territory has been
divided between France and Italy I mean
his native tongue was ligurian which is
more closely related to French and
Italian Sailors is a very young man and
he spent his adult life first in
Portugal and later in Spain although in
all fairness I should add that the
Spanish to
the Spanish do we actually recognize do
also consider one of their own so you
know there's I don't mean any
don't mean any disrespect for Italian
Americans I in fact made a point of
wearing an Italian tie today but um I
think uh I think we should have uh I
think we should have an indigenous
people's Day holiday on that same day to
honor um the indigenous peoples the
Americas who uh were here for thousands
of years before my European ancestors um
like my like like uh Mr like uh Mr wheat
she spoke earlier I have many ancestors
you go back way back to the first
European student colonize the United
States uh but uh you know we should have
so that's that's the holiday that I
think that's the American holiday that I
think we should have indigenous people's
day so that's uh
that's uh that's basically uh that's
basically
why I think this bill should be
passionately be happy to take any
questions
thank you representative O'Brien
ah thank you uh and thank you
representative for taking my question
we heard this uh very same build
facsimile like in the uh automatic
chamber in Nashville and I spoke on it
at the time uh your facts are correct
but then again uh the thing is
this is not just uh indigenous people
although I do support that they should
have their own day
is that this day has been adopted by the
Italian Community I grew up in Boston
even though I grew up in an Irish
neighborhood I recommend I recognize
that my Italian friends have adopted
Christopher Columbus to be one of their
own now I am all in favor of having
indigenous people stay in keeping
Columbus Day I can't and I want you to
try to convince me why should I throw my
Italian friends under the bus and get
rid of them completely I do know the
history of the United States that there
was situations where Italian immigrants
were murdered in these United States and
that the federal government did name
Columbus Day for that one year in
recognition to those people who were
murdered in that particular tragic
incident so it does have a tie to one
particular another race so why should we
throw that race out to make it better
for another race when we could probably
be more inclusive and give the
indigenous people their own very special
day
um
I mean this has been I'm uh I'm mostly
Irish um as you can tell by my name
which is uh
not quite as Irish as Michael O'Brien
but pretty close so you and we'll see
what Irish ancestry on my father's side
as you guessed from my name um
and we not sure how to answer
I'm not trying to show the Italian
Americans under the bus and I'm aware of
a lot of the the history I will say uh
our our national our ethnic holiday is
St Patrick's Day which um
that's about everybody people everybody
is Irish for that one day so that's
become you know a major celebration on
the calendar and we we do that without
any official permission whatsoever
except in uh except in Suffolk County
where you grew up representative Brian
where it is uh it is evacuation day but
every you know uh
and of course you know the indigenous
people say it's grown up without you
know without the name of the holiday
without the uh
without actually official recognition
but I think it should have official
recognition I do certainly I know from
my own experiences Irish American um you
know we can celebrate our we celebrate
our uh our heritage on St Patrick's day
without any official permission
whatsoever so I don't know really much
of a better answer than that since I'm
not trying to throw the Italian
Americans under the bus and uh
and actually Columbus's uh actually in
the Spanish-speaking world like uh
that's also become sort of a holiday of
the Spanish-speaking world because uh
Columbus uh is Columbus was it was
Spanish and in fact you know journey to
North America like
sort of on the payroll of the king and
queen of Spain so I'm not not trying to
throw anybody in the bus I'm just uh
just I'm just uh trying to uh recognize
indigenous peoples I'm not trying to
downgrade anybody anybody else so
thanks
ah thank you Mr chairman yeah
um yeah uh representative lecus please
uh this is for uh representative Oregon
so I mean I understand St Patty's Day
other than maybe that one exception is
handled by private observance and it's
very successful in that
so and uh
I guess and there's concern about
Columbus Day so to keep things uh
kind of fair for everybody would you be
supportive of removing or eliminating
official recognition of all such days
and leave it to the people who are
interested in private organizations to
take that on as it's done for Saint
Patrick's Day
[Music]
um
well no just as a practical matter we
have a holiday on the second Monday in
October I think it's good to have a
holiday
holiday in October for uh
you know for reasons Beyond just
indigenous people's day like in Canada
that's when they celebrate their
Thanksgiving so I think we should
continue to have an official holiday in
mid-october I I think uh the Columbus
Day celebration except amongst political
types uh is has kind of Gone by the
wayside so like the indigenous people's
day it's actually much more vibrant
celebration so October has become a
October Monday in October and the entire
month of October has has unofficially
become indigenous people say uh
business people's day uh celebration and
I think that should I think I think I
think we should uh honor that by uh
making an official holiday because we
are we did my ancestors on a well
especially my mother's side uh
she's a part Irish but mostly English
and Scottish internment they did uh
frankly you know steal the continent
from uh from the native peoples who are
living there peacefully and uh in fact
actually
um I even know some
some of my relatives were even related
to George Washington so like I'm
partially
so they're partially to blame for what
happened when he judged we heard about a
few minutes ago so you know that's uh
I'm you know I'm proud of their proud of
some of what my ancestors did and
ashamed of ashamed of others but I think
uh I think we need to I think we need to
honor the uh honor the people who whose
uh land who we are occupying so that's
that's why uh that's what I think that's
why that's why I think we need the
official indigenous people's day
holidays so thank you representative
Oregon will you take questions
oh sure why not yes
no are there is are there any questions
okay thank you very much well thank you
madam chair so
uh good afternoon honorable members of
the committee my name is Amanda
Elizabeth toll I represent Cheshire 16
which encompasses the city of Keene at
large I am here in support of HB 155
this bill renames Columbus Day as
indigenous people's day for the purposes
of the state holiday the history of
colonization and the violence that came
along with it should not be celebrated
instead of honoring the oppressor let's
honor celebrate and learn about the
history and culture of Native Americans
I'm going to defer questions thank you
for hearing my testimony
hi uh my system just rebooted uh I'm uh
representative Jess Edwards representing
Auburn Chester and Sandown uh today I'm
coming to the committee introducing two
amendments
the the central theme of these two
amendments is that it recognizes and
leverages the good work of the United
Nations which designated in 1972 in a
World's indigenous people's day as
August 9th and uh and given
all of the Enlightenment that's happened
to us over the last 40 50 years I think
it's really important to
um to be the change we wish to see in
others that we should be looking for
ways to be more inclusive and to
celebrate more cultures and so for that
reason I I do think that an indigenous
people's day is is an appropriate way to
go I my amendments put it on August 9th
so that it is consistent with a world
holiday
um and that way we can just leverage
Global celebrations I I would like to
leave Columbus Day alone out of the
spirit of inclusiveness
there seems to be an explicit effort to
destroy and rewrite a major part of
American History that's in here
um and I I don't think that's
particularly wise I I would say that if
we look at history and if we'll look at
mankind throughout history
civilization has always been a very
fragile thing
and the the thing that destroys
civilizations is uh the scarcity and we
we stand here now in 2021 in a land
where we take our luxuries for granted
everything we need we can get pretty
quickly and and we don't operate in the
scarcity of 500 years ago we we can't
judge directly the the man's inhumanity
to man 500 years ago but what we can
honor if we continue to recognize
Columbus Day is the spirit of
exploration and the and and the idea
that the uh that that this nation has
been developed primarily by an
Explorer's spirit and that that Explorer
spirit is with us still as we go to
we've gone to the Moon as we continue to
explore space and we continue to explore
the ocean I think Columbus Day is still
a great reminder of an important part of
the American Spirit and and there's I I
get that we want to acknowledge the
Native Americans who were here before uh
Europeans began to settle
um I get that but I think to be fair if
we were to go back 500 years and start
to look at the Native Americans their
cultures probably had violence they
probably had rape they probably had
man's inhumanity to man because that was
just life 500 years ago and we're not
living then so uh I I I would hope that
you would positively consider one of the
two amendments you can either name
August 9th as a world indigenous
people's day or just simply indigenous
people's day directly after the ibanki
tribe of uh it's that certainly lived in
this region so
um so I I think uh I think what we need
to do is spread love and not hate
so I'll take questions if you have any
thank you very much representative
Edwards representative
there's a question from Mr Edwards
um representative Edwards I'm sorry Mr
Edwards representative did I say that
yeah well apologies
um
you rightly expressed concern I have to
I'm sorry I have to provide a little
context before I connect my question the
rightly expressed concern about the fact
that 500 years ago there was violence
everywhere
and should we be celebrating this with
an indigenous people's day at all is
going to be my question but let me
provide a little context to the
indigenous peoples of the Americas and
the Caribbean basis Basin because we we
know that Columbus didn't land on North
America
like all of the peoples of the world
including the Europeans
war and Conquest were a way of life
by way of example the Arawaks who
dominated the northern Caribbean Basin
were quite roll out uh warlike making
sex slaves of their women captives
castrating or eating their male captives
this wasn't limited to the aloe act but
this was similar for the Brazilian to
penamba similar for the Brazilian I'm
sorry for the Peruvian Uki Ali the
Toshiba the Aztec the Mayans and other
prominent tribes and Nations
War making ritual sacrifice cannibalism
and slave taking are these the
principles that we're trying to advance
in replacement of Columbus Day
uh and I'll just uh I'll leave it there
and
ask you to answer that and address it in
any way you choose well thank you for
the question I I would say that
um given the luxuries that we have today
that we should look at the history of
mankind as a source of learning about
ways to improve civilization that
eradicating the past and and not
exploiting the positive parts of it uh
is is a mistake like for example the
Magna Carta was founded or written in uh
1066 I believe so so even though there's
much to criticize
European culture uh against uh that the
the 500 years ago there's also great
things to celebrate and and I I think
that we ought to be able to do both we
ought to be able to celebrate and we
ought to be able to identify
the things that we think need to be
improved whether it's in European
Society American society you know the
Native Americans weren't perfect so we
should not idealize them in a way that
creates a mythology of on its own that
somebody 40 years from now is going to
come back and try to eradicate so I I
just think we we share the maturity to
look at the totality of history in in
man's development and how fragile
civilization is and and just work to
make ours stronger and better and you do
that by including people you don't do
that by isolating groups and diminishing
them that that that's destructive thank
you I agree with you
thank you madam chair I'm glad to see
you in our committee representative
um
two things one is
um did you know that there still are
indigenous people living in New
Hampshire and my second
um question is did you know that this
bill comes from a movement that's
already taken hold in lots of places in
New Hampshire
to specifically replace Columbus Day
I I think I know both of those things
um uh I I I would just say that it's
great that this issue is coming before
the legislature so that we can take a
look at it overall for the state and and
put our own stamp on it for what it
should be and I'm recommending that uh
to you as a fellow legislator that you
join with me in believing that Society
needs to be tolerant and inclusive in
that there's a perfectly great way of
doing that by using the August 9th date
that's already recognized by the U.N to
recognize our local indigenous people
without having to insult or offend a
whole other group and so so like I said
I think this is the time to be inclusive
and tolerant and not intentionally seek
to diminish another culture or another
history I don't I just I don't think
that's healthy and it's okay for us as
elected representatives to say that on
I don't think you agree with me but
thank you representative Edwards are
there additional questions for
okay thank you very much thank you so
much Madam chairman and committee
Representatives
James Schmidt
good afternoon uh thank you very much
and uh thanks honorable uh chairwoman
and members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Jan Schmidt and I
represent Ward one in Nashua
uh Civil War statues are coming down
those monuments that store deep and
painful memories for some Americans of
the violence loss death from family
history it's not very distant and
this change is moving around the country
now think on Columbus Day is the same
celebration it it if it gives you an
evocative feeling for the people who are
asking for those Civil War statues to
come down that they feel the pain that
they were on the losing side and
reminded every single time
um
some people of Italian descent seem to
think that this day is to celebrate
their Heritage akin to Saint Patty's Day
for the people of Irish descent but it
really isn't it's a Federal holiday and
it's assigned to a single person if it
was Italian-American day that would be
wonderful uh Italian-American Heritage
day
all these ideas are really terrific but
for right now I think it's time to get
rid of Columbus Day and I think it's the
best way to honor the people the people
who are here before us
make it about the indigenous people it's
time to celebrate the first people and
this is a really good move thank you for
hearing my testimony I'll take any
questions
all right thank you are there questions
I don't see any so thank you for your
testimony thank you very much
hi um I'm just a member of the public
I'm doing I haven't done this before is
it okay to testify yes to tell it where
you're from and then then start talking
okay I am from Campton New Hampshire
um I am a professor of early American
literature and history with an expertise
um in Columbus and I'm also Italian so
it's uh it's a great day for me to be
here
um I am speaking in support of this bill
for two main reasons um the first is
um as an Italian-American uh this is
um not one of the things that I am
culturally proud of
um you are probably aware
of Columbus's impact on the native
people but sometimes when people use the
word genocide they think that that word
is being tossed around casually
um but with the indigenous people of
Haiti we are talking about going from a
population of about 3 million to a
population of zero we're talking not
just about cultural genocide but of the
total wiping out of a of a race of of
human beings
um so in terms of my Italian Pride I
have a lot of it but not for this
particular man he's also
um credited with starting in many ways
the transatlantic slave trade and in
terms of women and sexual slavery uh was
really integral in selling both
um native women and young Native girls
to his Admirals in exchange for uh land
so the more you learn this doesn't come
from history books um this actually
comes from Columbus's own journals
written both in his own hand and the
Hand of the classes who traveled with
him and his son who traveled with him so
that's where my information comes from
there's plenty of direct quotes and I'd
be happy to share those with you if if
they're of interest
um so I'm not proud as an Italian the
other thing is that indigenous people's
day there are you know indigenous
peoples are
um uh diverse they speak different
languages they are different cultures
um there are you know
um all sorts of aspects to indigenous
culture but part of what we're honoring
when we change the name to indigenous
people's day is the survival amongst
many tribes in the face of the genocide
by
um by Columbus and the history of the
Conquistadors who followed him so I
absolutely think it's an appropriate
switch
um and uh and and definitely time we've
done this in many places in New
Hampshire already I'm proud of my own
campus where I'm a professor at Plymouth
State University when we changed our
calendar after students advocated to
make this shift and we now have
indigenous peoples day on our University
calendar so I encourage you to read
Columbus's words directly
and to not discount
your Italian friends because we have a
lot of Pride about a lot of things about
our culture that are are truly beautiful
but Christopher Columbus is not one of
them thank you for your time and thank
representative Schultz
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my question Ms DeRosa Professor
DeRosa um
so since you're a history professor and
in Italian maybe you can help clarify a
point that is probably going to come up
again I think it came up today it comes
up often with this bill is the notion of
celebrating Italian Heritage and is it
safe to say that when this holiday when
Columbus Day specifically was
um popularized in communities that it
was a very different
um atmosphere around being Italian at
that time too and how do you think that
atmosphere has changed
um that is true so first I have to put a
disclaimer in that I am a history of
early America so 1400
um to about 1800 pre-civil war is my
period so when you're talking about
Columbus Day and then Italian
immigration you're actually quite past
my period um but I've learned some
amazing things from my uh colleague at
Plymouth State John kruegerberg who um
writes and talks about this quite a bit
um but obviously there was a time in our
history when Italian Americans were
discriminated discriminated against
similarly to Irish Americans
um so we have that sort of immigrant
history that still inflexus my family is
all um from Boston they grew up uh
working class after my grandparents
immigrated here
um and they you know suffered some of
them didn't speak English and they were
challenged so I understand the need for
Italian pride in a community that has
been historically described terminated
against that discrimination is very
different than the Discrimination that
Native Americans currently face in our
culture as an Italian-American I have
not faced any discrimination and the
barriers that my families have faced
growing up I think have have sort of
generationally become much much milder
um my my grandparents
were very excited about the Boston
Columbus Day parades at no time did I
ever hear them excited about Christopher
Columbus what they were excited about
was a chance to celebrate their um their
culture their food their language and I
think that could have happened at any
kind of Italian Pride Parade which I
would certainly be happy to endorse
doing that in the name of Christopher
Columbus I think is uh is a mistake and
in terms of the rewriting of History one
of the representatives talked about we
spent many many decades rewriting
history many high school textbooks still
mischaracterize Columbus as the
discoverer of America and
mischaracterized him as the first person
who thought the world was round of
course you're aware I think that he
actually thought the world was shaped
like a pair whereas everybody else
scientifically at that time thought the
world was round we spent a lot of time
rewriting The Narrative of what Columbus
believed all we're doing now is
correcting many many years of
um of of really just flat out wrong
information that was transmitted mostly
through our through our schools for for
political reasons so it's it's time to
fix that and we can still preserve
Italian Heritage and pride without
relying on the lies that shaped The
yeah thank you are there other questions
yes yes representative Mr Rosa are you
from Hampton or New Hampton
uh Camden with a c Hampton sorry thank
you yes
foreign
yes I'm right next door to Plymouth
State trying to survive our our covet
other questions
thank you Professor thank you Peter
petrigno I would point out that it's
snowing
yes
absolutely
hello Madam chair
hello okay you can hear me thank you
madam chair members of the committee
I'm representative Peter Petrino from
Hillsboro 23 in the town of Milford
so I'd like to say that I very much
would like to see a day of recognition
for Native Americans
but this particular bill
has me personally conflicted
as a proud Italian American I cannot in
good conscience support this bill to do
so would be for me to disrespect and
dishonor my family my parents my
grandparents my heritage
this is not to say that I support
Columbus Day
I recognize that many no longer hold
Columbus in a place of honor most of us
never knew or considered the atrocities
his Expeditions perpetrated upon native
peoples so it's appropriate for us to
re-examine the Past
however aside from Columbus the man and
his deeds October 12th has long been
celebrated by the Italian-American
Community as a matter of ethnic pride in
their rightful place in America
so is it possible for us not to throw
out the baby with the bathwater that is
not to recognize Columbus but to
continue to celebrate Italian-American
Heritage now it should be noted that in
New Hampshire
we rank seventh in the nation in terms
of the percentage of citizens who are
Italian-American
seventh
that's a pretty high number
now there is some history that many are
not aware of
that may provide some context to this
discussion
back in 1891 David Hennessey the police
chief of New Orleans was murdered and
Italian immigrants was suspect
subsequently 250 Italian immigrants were
rounded up eventually nine went on trial
for murder
they were later acquitted however
following the acquittal on March 14 1891
an angry mob of thousands gathered
outside of the jail and a mob stormed
inside very similar to what happened to
our nation's capital just last month
and 11 Italian prisoners were killed
nine was shot or clubbed to death into a
hauled outside and they were hung and
shot
this is one of the largest single mass
lynchings in American history and it's
been said that this has been
referred to as the lynching that gave us
Columbus Day
now upset by these events in New Orleans
and the hash treatment of Italians
across the country president Benjamin
Harrison decided to honor Italians with
a special presidential Proclamation
he considered the number of prominent
Italians to recognize from Galileo to
Leonardo da Vinci but he eventually
settled upon Columbus since the
following year in 1892 it marked the
400th anniversary of his Landing in the
Western Hemisphere so it was a
fortuitous coincidence
now needless to say Italian Americans
were Overjoyed finally their time had
come the president of the United States
had officially acknowledged their place
in our country
and my grandparents arrived at Ellis
Island from Italy a little over a decade
later and settled in Boston's Little
Italy the North End where I grew up and
were members of my family still live
now since president Harrison's
Proclamation there were a number of
movements for permanent recognition
Italians had been celebrating Columbus
Day unofficially in New York City as far
back as 1866 but the first legal holiday
was in Colorado in 1905 and then of
course eventually it became a national
holiday in 1971.
now last year Colorado became first
again
addressing the controversy surrounding
Columbus Day while continuing to
recognize Italian Americans
Colorado replaced Columbus Day with
Cabrini day
commonly known as Mother Cabrini Francis
Xavier Cabrini was an Italian nun who
came to the United States in 1889 and
she became an American citizen and she
worked with the sick and the poor she
established numerous schools hospitals
and orphanages throughout the United
States
she is the first United States citizen
to be canonized the Saints in the
Catholic church and Cabrini day is the
first paid holiday in the United States
to recognize a woman
so
considering all of this I asked the
committee to think about retaining this
bill to explore a way for us to
recognize Native Americans while at the
same time continuing the
long-established recognition of Italian
Americans and without Columbus
now I know there are those who disagree
with my position including some very
good friends of mine in in the house
but I'm here looking for a middle way
I would never ask anyone to support
legislation that with dishonor any
aspect of who they are where they came
from or their heritage
I pray the day comes when we extend to
all without prejudice the respect and
dignity that we each deserve thank you
so much Madam chair and committee for
listening to my testimony and I'll be
not not from the committee so thank you
thank you
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee thank you very much
this hearing takes place on indakina now
called New Hampshire the traditional
ancestral homeland of the Abenaki
Penacook and wabanaki peoples past and
present
we acknowledge and honor with gratitude
the land and waterways and the alnabak
the people who have stewarded in lakina
throughout the many millennia
I'm Kathleen Blake I am a woman with
indigenous Heritage and four
Northeastern Woodlands tribes and I'm
chair of the New Hampshire Commission on
Native American Affairs
administratively attached to the
Department of cultural resources the
commission on Native American Affairs
recognizes the historic and cultural
contributions of Native Americans to New
Hampshire promotes and strengthens
Native American Heritage and furthers
the needs of New Hampshire's Native
American community Through State policy
and programs
as such we fully endorse House Bill 155
and strongly recommend that this bill so
important to the indigenous citizens of
New Hampshire be passed
furthermore we do not endorse the
continued celebration of Columbus Day in
any capacity and therefore reject the
proposed amendment
I now speak as a private citizen
I gave serious thought to re-reading my
comments from last year or perhaps from
the year before
I remember a comment that one of you
made
last year and I quote about this being a
left-handed attempt at reparations
I vividly recalled the vote of last
year's Bill and sitting in the gallery
watching huge numbers of elected
officials walk out during the discussion
about indigenous People's State Bill and
return to vote to table it
I thought about making comments about
how this is not about Italian people as
I did last year in the year before and
again this year
I recall educating this body about the
horrific acts of murder of rape of
enslavement and of kidnapping that began
the genocide of our indigenous peoples
in this hemisphere
I thought back on Dr Richard beauvair
retired New Hampshire State
archaeologist informing this body that
this state has been inhabited by the
indigenous people for at least twelve
thousand five hundred years and so yes
we did live here and we still do
but then I remembered that with the two
previous spills you already have heard
all this I see all of your faces that I
saw last year
so nothing is new here
we shared quotes from The Diary of
Christopher Columbus himself and of
others who traveled with him that proved
beyond the shadow of adult of a doubt
that they committed atrocities that defy
all reason
and you know that
you know that
I was raised by Republicans
my dear parents taught me that if
something wrong was done
you recognize it you admit it and you
make it right
until this very moment the state of New
Hampshire celebrates the horrors that
happened in the man who made them happen
you know that Christopher Columbus never
stepped foot on this land
he did not discover these United States
you know the evil that was done by him
and his men
you know that our indigenous ancestors
were the first people to live here
so I asked this question
why
why do you vote to continue to celebrate
a lie to celebrate atrocities to
celebrate genocide
I challenge each of you to answer that
question if not here in a public forum
then in the Silence of your own home
doing the right thing is not a partisan
issue
it's a that's an excuse
there is a right thing to do here
and once again I hope you have the
courage to do it
thank you for listening to my words and
if you have any questions I'll be happy
to answer them
thank you Miss Blake you're welcome
I don't see any questions so thank you
foreign
yes just very briefly I I was in error
before when I implied that the arrow
Acts were cannibals and more like they
were not it was the carobs and it was
actually the carobs that wiped out the
I'm sorry can can you hear me yes
I sorry this is my first time doing this
on Zoom
um should I start over was I not please
introduce yourself and then start over
yes thank you sorry
um
hi my name is Amy antonucci I live in
Barrington New Hampshire
and I'd like to express my support for
establishing an indigenous people's day
to take the place of Columbus Day I am
especially speaking as an
Italian-American woman
I personally have no interest in being
connected with a violent and oppressive
man
um
well I really do appreciate the work
that Italians did
who came before me did to remove
so much prejudice against
Italians in the U.S
at this point we know so much more
about Columbus and the violence that he
committed
continuing to hold him up is someone to
honor and be associated with it's just
not something that I want
um
my father was a huge believer in social
to get honest about our history and to
make amends where we can
um and then partly in his name Giovanni
antonucci I want to you know be here
doing this
I'd also like to
um
offer the words of Pope Francis in July
2015.
when he said I say this to you with
regret many grave sins were committed
against the native people of America in
the name of God I humbly ask forgiveness
not only for the offense of the church
herself but also for crimes committed
against the native peoples during the
so it's in that spirit that I support
ending Columbus Day and instead enacting
an indigenous people's day here in New
Hampshire that's what would make me feel
the most proud of my Heritage and my
name and I will also say that my family
is also
a real fan of Mother Cabrini and was
very excited that a statue in New York
was recently dedicated to her and she is
more along the lines someone who helped
the poor the sick and other immigrants
here in this country that is more the
kind of person that we do want to that I
do want to be associated with
thank you
thank you for your testimony is there
anyone who wishes to ask questions
[Music]
um thank you Miss Anthony tanucci I
would love to if you don't mind sending
me the quote from Pope Francis and am I
correct isn't he even though he's from
Argentina I think is he from Italian
Heritage also
I'm happy to send you the quote and I am
not really
completely sure of his Heritage so I
won't I won't say anything on that there
are other historians and historic other
folks will know better than me I think
maybe representative Schultz is could
thank you representative schuette has a
question
thank you madam chair not not actually a
question I just wanted to recognize that
I sense that Miss antonucci was very
nervous about testifying and I just
wanted to assure her that she did a good
job but thank her because it's important
to hear from our constituents so thanks
for being brave enough
thank you I appreciate it
yes representative Schmidt
thank you very much Miss uh Madam chair
and miss antonucci
uh it's very nice to see you again
a friend of long long-standing you and
your husband are all frequently in my
thoughts uh I really appreciate her
being here today
and as a strong supporter of this bill
I'm I'm wondering
um is it in any way
reasonable or correct for for
us to see in Christopher Columbus any
aspect of Italian culture a nation which
um as having studied
the Latin language
from my 14th year and until I graduated
from high school and having studied
Italian culture virtually all my life
I'm wondering does Christopher Columbus
in any way
deserve to be celebrated as and as
Exemplar of Italian culture
well
well I I don't think so
um and I was not raised with him as an
important part really of my family or my
Heritage
um he wasn't really held up as someone
that we were proud of
um
I've again people like Mother Cabrini
and so many artists and there's really
many wonderful Italians and
um Christopher Columbus is not one that
is on my
list as being
um
or that I was raised to think of as
someone that we wanted to be associated
with
so I don't think so I I do very much
understand the history of coming to the
holiday and I think there are some
important pieces you know that people
very much were working to make this
country
a better place for someone like me to
live and I deeply appreciate that and I
think the history of it and the massacre
that took place and there's some things
there that we can you know
that it's good that we're learning about
I'm I know I'm very happy to learn more
of that history
um but I I don't feel that Christopher
Columbus needs to be
the important part of that
thank you
greetings to The Honorable New Hampshire
house executive departments and
administrative committee and Madam
chairman hello I'm Paul puglio and with
me is my wife Denise we represent the
indigenous community of the kosek abneki
people on record with the Secretary of
State New Hampshire and attorney general
is being headquartered here in Alton New
Hampshire we seek a favorable
determination on HB 155 in regard to
renaming Columbus Day as indigenous
peoples today
any other effort to create an
alternative day for indigenous people
stay such as August 9th uh would be to
avoid the truth about America and it's
it's really inconsistent with the
historical truth and as such
continuously Narrative of social
injustice
it is true idpj is an international
movement to correct history and
recognize the contributions and
sacrifices of indigenous people here and
worldwide but these are our lands in the
United States not in Australia or some
other place where August 9th may have
made sense these lands are ours for more
than ten thousand years before Europeans
many of our numerous contributions and
sacrifices to U.S society past and
present not excluding taking on land's
resources and our lives we're always
overlooked it is taught it's time to
really stop honoring the false Narrative
of European and religious superiority
and to honor the original indigenous
people that have given so much to this
country in the world
now is the time to discuss the facts of
this holiday it's based on events that
no civilized country should be honoring
Columbus in his own words describes the
atrocities of genocide that he and his
men and those explorers of the new the
age of Discovery committed against
indigenous people of the new world
a time when European rule is attempting
to divide and control the world
take over newly discovered land seeking
the resources of gold in their peoples
as slaves
during the 1500s Spain which no no most
people don't understand had a formal
plan of Jewish genocide removing seeds
to lands and property of the Jewish
Jewish community in the Iberian
Peninsula spoken about the fact that
those stolen assets of these Jewish
people helped fund Columbus's Global
ambitions
let's go back to Columbus
he was born in 1451 he was born in the
Republic of Genoa
Italy was not formally created until
1861 400 years later he was never truly
an Italian in that sense
Colombo actually lived most of his life
in Portugal and Spain Columbus as he got
renamed was actually an agent of a
Spanish royalty
and essentially a mercenary Explorer in
exploit a fahaya he made four trips to
the Caribbean explored the area around
Cuba in hispanual but he never set foot
on North America and had no historical
connection to the United States
the Vikings like previously said were
probably the first true Europeans that
landed in the Americas
meeting the indigenous people which he
mistakenly called Indians a name we
still have to live with he commented on
how gentle healthy peaceful kind they
were to him and his men in his own words
they knew not what iron was they had no
defensive weapons and will be easily
enslaved
is started and fervored the slavery
movement in the Americas when he brought
back the first indigenous slaves to
Europe which in turn promoted the global
expansion of slavery into the Americas
and into the Atlantic and that didn't
end until the mid-1800s
we could go on about as numerous acts of
Cruelty and genocide during his visits
to the Caribbean they were so brutal and
descriptive it was shameful these were
acts of brutality a horrific nature
against peaceful men and women and
children who had no resources to defend
themselves these atrocities were
committed at acts of entertainment for
his men this is how we controlled and
dominate those he preferred and he
wanted to make peaceful indigenous
people that he would put into
enslavement
it's a holiday you know Columbus day has
been observed in various communities
with Italian immigrants from the late 18
1700s it started in New York and and in
in Boston as well as a nationalist
movement for Italians it was promoted by
the Knights of Columbus which was
established in 1882. most of uh we have
to reflect now on most of our national
and state holidays were set with very
high standards and reasons for making an
honoring holiday
now that we know some of the facts
surrounding Columbus would you consider
re-establishing a holiday to honor him
today I question whether that would make
sense this is not a matter of honoring
Italians this is about the continuing
honoring of a man who committed genocide
slavery in many acts against humanity
this is about correcting the Injustice
of history in the Americas
to the Counterpoint we would very
strongly support a special Italian
holiday to honor people like Leonardo da
Vinci Galileo Marco Polo Marconi for
many and many many of us some of which
were known to be U.S citizens and did
great things for the America
so with that I say thank you please vote
uh approval for HB 155 we thank you a
written testimony has been submitted by
email as well thank you very much
thank you for your testimony are there
nope I don't see anything thank you
again
uh
[Music]
yes can you hear me yes thank you okay
yes yeah my name is ismaelini and I'm
speaking in strong support of this bill
um this is literally a continuation of
the racism we refuse to make right I
also want to start off by acknowledging
the land that we're on and respect the
ability people who are the proper
stewards of the land that we are all on
now
um it is not okay that we're over here
and we want to respect the wishes of
some Italians that need a hero in a man
who brought genocide while disrespecting
the Italians who are saying this is not
the proper way to celebrate Italian
Heritage in this state why would we want
to rob a man who took thousands of
indigenous people as slaves and utilize
it utilized them
um took selling women into sexual
slavery and murdered so many people this
is not honoring a culture it's honoring
a man who brought genocide on a people
as some Italians have already said so
eloquent currently this is not the
Italian History that they are proud of
and not the Italian History our state
should be a proud of so we should not be
celebrating the spirit of exploration
that destroys a people and a culture
what kind of message would that be
sending to our children like let's
explore and it's okay to hurt people
while we're exploring no so we're just
respecting people by keeping Columbus
Day it's a slap on the face for people
that we never really did right by from
our mistakes so
also this is not about including history
we should never remove the history that
everyone needs to know about it's about
honoring bad history instead of looking
at this is a sad part of our history so
this day should have been removed long
ago and it's time we make things right
in a small Way by naming this indigenous
people's day as a token of acknowledging
the harms done to a community that we
acknowledge their presence still today
and that they still face so much
discrimination even today for these
reasons we should have removed this day
long ago and honor those who deserve to
be honored and we have yet Done Right by
so please vote Yes on this bill
thank you for your testimony are there
seeing none
thank you again
is there anyone else who wishes to
.
I tried to call
this is Catherine corkery
yes representative Schmidt I see that
there's somebody else there who has we
have six people who have raised their
hand and I'm going to be calling on all
of them
well I I applaud your efforts to try to
contact Mr Thomas but uh so perhaps Miss
corkery is using will Thomas's cell
phone
no
can you hear me now yes there you are
thank you I apologize I'm having some
computer problems with my ancient
computer uh for the record and thank you
uh Madam chairman and uh members of the
committee uh for the record uh my name
is William Thomas and I reside in Auburn
New Hampshire
I am a retired uh Civics and history
teacher at Manchester Central High
School and I am supporting uh House Bill
155 replacing Columbus Day uh I'm just
curious if anybody received the uh
written testimony I sent in
yes we did thank you okay thank you so
let me start by saying I uh I I I taught
history but I'm not really a historian
but I think history and I would mention
uh and I always did mention my students
let's not forget her story in thinking
of Granny D and owner judge and the
woman in Dover and others who have you
know through the years been uh largely
forgotten but anyway I think history or
history invites us to re-examine what we
think we know about history or her story
often by discovering new sources of
information especially and I tried to
emphasize this with my students in
looking at not just their textbook but
other uh information in terms of primary
sources what is a primary source what is
a secondary source uh third hand Source
Etc and we we do know has been mentioned
previously that Columbus kept a journal
we know that the Spanish priest the Las
Casas who accompanied him on three of
his voyages kept a journal we know they
exist they're in Spain they've been
translated and so we have evidence in
the Admiral's own words about the sexual
slavery about the uh the genocide that
he and his men initiated
so and I think of uh and I've used a
textbook called The People's History of
the United States by Howard Zen at least
the first chapter excerpts called
Columbus the Indians and human progress
or lack thereof and
Zen comments on one famous historian
from Harvard uh Samuel Elliott Morrison
who actually replicated by taking a a
ship tracing Columbus's Voyage the first
uh from Spain through the Canary Islands
to the Bahamas
and
interestingly uh Morrison admired
Columbus tremendously and uh at the same
time he said yeah he had some flaws he
had some uh
uh problems but but basically he praised
his semenship and I read other stories
uh accounts by historians where the
other two uh captains of the of the
three ships that went to on the first
voyage were better Pilots uh than
Columbus but anyway then you have on the
opposite side
we see this historian David standard
saying the destruction of the Indians of
the Americas was Far and Away the most
active Act of genocide in the history of
the world and by the way uh now it comes
to mind I forget the representative
Italian from I think Milford who who did
comment on the Italians who were killed
in 1891. my account where I read that
was it was 13 Sicilian and I'm not sure
if if
not denigrating either Italians or
Sicilians but but uh that was the
comment I recall reading so another
historian and this is important I think
to point out uh his name was basil
Davidson
he assigns responsibility to to Columbus
for initiating the African slave trade
to the Americas he said the first
license granted and he did his research
to send enslaved Africans to the
Caribbean was issued by the king and
queen in 1501 when Columbus himself was
the ruler in the Indies leading Davidson
to dub Columbus the father of the slave
trade so again when we think of honoring
this man
not only with the genocide of some
historians have estimated over a hundred
million he initiated that plus the
African slave trade I I I have to say I
I don't think he is worthy of that honor
and so this is why I do support uh
indigenous peoples today and one last
thing
uh there's an acquaintance of mine who's
a retired teacher who's the editor of a
magazine called rethinking schools his
name is Bill Bigelow and and Mr Bigelow
says if indigenous peoples lives matter
in our society and if black people's
lives mattered in our society it would
be inconceivable that we would honor the
father of the slave trade with a
national holiday
the fact that we have this holiday
legitimizes a curriculum that is
contemptuous of the lives of people of
color
Elementary School libraries still
feature books like quote follow the
dream the story of Christopher Columbus
by Peter sis s-i-s
who which Praises Columbus and says
nothing of the life destroyed by Spanish
colonialism in the Americas so basically
uh I mean I know Durham Hopkinton I know
cities like Minneapolis Seattle and I
think Portland Alaska was the first
state to declare indigenous people's day
it's it's something that's going on is
occurring uh International in the U.N
indigenous peoples day of spine except
when we we stop and reflect about the
force being cut down in the Amazon where
indigenous people live in Madagascar
Madagascar Etc uh that's not really
honoring them as well a day we need to
make real uh what happened and and what
happened was a genocide a holocaust if
you will of indigenous people so I'd be
glad to answer any questions
thank you Mr Thomas are there questions
hope seeing none thank you for your
testimony
thank you madam chair members of the
House my name is Tristan McLean
um just restating I am speaking on
behalf of myself as a member of the
public and as a resident of Plymouth New
Hampshire
I myself was raised by Italian Americans
um
third generation hallmarked by
two generations of service to the Air
Force and service on the Bristol and
Groton Police Department I was brought
up in a very extremely conservative
household
um was taught how to properly and
responsibly use a gun
with a pretty sharp um
range as well however
Christopher Columbus was not ever
celebrated in our household or nor and
any other generations of our family
um
I really don't think it's a moment of
Pride for Italian Americans I know no
one in my family
would definitely support him being
celebrated
and as all branch and in the spirit of
inclusion I ask why don't you celebrate
January 7th known as Flag Day in Italy
or something to that effect
um I can't remember the other prior
holiday I think it was kabini I
apologize if I'm asking her that
pronunciation I think that would be an
adequate substitution
now an acknowledgment of my Native
American Heritage I am a descendant of
an Abenaki tribe whose knowledge I do
not have due to it being lost by
generational alcoholism
now I think that the trauma is inflicted
by
Columbus's
brutal imperialistic campaign where he
was even brought back to Spain and tried
for his crimes
and was actually exiled for many
European countries due to them
I really don't think this is someone
that merits any celebration other than
maybe the fact that he couldn't even
um
nobody's trying to slight Italian
Americans but
I just can't really understand where
this sentiment's coming from
this holiday wasn't even conceived until
the 1970s
so why don't we stop with this
information and start speaking to the
truth thank you very much
thank you Mr Klein are there any other
Jennifer Smith
hello um
uh there's time I've done this I didn't
realize this was speak I'm sorry
um I have to rename this because this is
Sarah Smith
um I'm Sarah Smith I uh it I live in
Pembroke New Hampshire
um I've represented here by Diane
schuett
um uh I'm a retired school teacher and I
would like to um
bring to your attention that
that uh holidays are celebrated in
schools
um and part of the curriculum
is to celebrate the holidays the social
studies curriculum of the second graders
is to celebrate learn about the holidays
that we celebrate so
um I would like you to picture uh
a bunch of seven-year-olds
learning about Christopher Columbus
and how would it and knowing what we
know about Christopher Columbus now
would you have the teachers lie to them
about what he did
how would you have them approach it
celebrating this man whatever if you
tell them that well just sanitize it
don't say anything about that other
stuff because it really is too shocking
for second graders
to learn about
um then then they begin they've had a
false history planted in their mind
and these false histories have a
tendency to last a long time as you're
probably aware having Having learned
several of them so my question for you
is are you aware of the fact that as you
celebrate this as you put this as a
holiday for New Hampshire You're
Expecting second graders to learn about
it
so that that's this is my this is my
point I'm just I'm in favor of changing
this to indigenous people's day because
I think this is really too um terrible a
history to teach to young children
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
foreign
hello how's everyone doing today my name
is Anthony Harris
um I'm po I'm calling in testifying and
support of hb155
um
I remember being in elementary school
and they're teaching us about Columbus
Day and how he discovered America and he
was this great guy they painted him to
be this beautiful man and and someone
that you can look up to and Inspire to
become
but then as I get older and I do my own
studies and I realize who he really is
it makes me look at the American
government
and why would you celebrate someone who
was such a horrible person a horrific
figure someone that we would call a
monster today
we would lock up and throw away the key
and in some states he will be have the
lethal injection for the atrocities that
he committed on the people
and that would be in any country
so if as America being
one of the greatest countries on this
planet
why would we want to celebrate this
and to teach our kids
now we're lying to our kids throughout
history and then it's up to us to
deprogram them from these lies that the
I need the ones who controlling this
bill
I need you to look and say
would you sit down with your
granddaughters and your grandsons and
would you teach them how wonderful
Christopher Columbus is
and how you can aspire to become just
like him let's celebrate him on this day
how would you feel in yourself in your
heart and your souls to the god that you
pray to
do you really feel comfortable
not changing this day from Columbus Day
to the indigenous people's day
ask yourself these questions
in yourselves
in your own hearts would you teach your
children
and your loved ones that this was a
horrible God this was a fantastic God
and you can model yourself after it
if you want then you should put hb50 uh
155 you should push this through
thank you and have a beautiful day God
bless you all
good afternoon can you hear me yes sir
thank you
thank you thank you for the opportunity
to offer testimony this afternoon my
name is Carissa Coro I live in Penacook
on Stolen Abernathy land and for 12
years I taught literature to high school
students here our first unit of American
literature focused on creation myths and
first-hand accounts from early
colonizers through these readings my
students came to an understanding that
the Columbus they have been taught to
admire in elementary school for his
bravery and perseverance as an explorer
was by many accounts including his own a
pretty terrible human being in fact as
we heard before his actions were so
horrific he was returned to Spain and
shackles and stripped of his
governorship
some of my students were really upset
that they had been essentially lied to
which we which you just heard in
testimony
um that we would put someone so terrible
on a pedestal in our school district in
eighth grade they spent quite a lot of
time studying the Holocaust in
preparation for the trip to Washington
DC and so
um they know what genocide looks like in
terms of reading about it and they knew
that this is what occurred and so their
question was why were their elementary
teachers do this to them why would they
learn about Columbus at all why this
holiday and so I don't know um if you
know the answer but part of it is
connected to historical fiction I'm
greatly embellished by Washington Irving
and repackaged to elementary school
children in our country as a way to
celebrate the colonies and U.S
Independence there's a lot in Irving's
account of Columbus that we still
believe today including the ship's names
which aren't actually the Nina and the
pink death they have other names so this
campaign so successful that we still
hold these shoes to this day even though
we have new truths and we understand
things
um for me upholding
um Irving's Christopher Columbus is like
using the musical Hamilton uh to
actually teach the events of the
American Revolution
um so when folks talk about rewriting
history Irving helped to do this
um so as a class we inevitably ended up
with this question how do you teach
elementary students about Columbus so it
was really well what would you want your
teachers to do so um I gave them a task
to create a children's book that was
both honest and um that was what they
thought was age-appropriate for
elementary students and it was difficult
um because how do you explain to
students elementary students that one of
our national holidays celebrates a man
who's responsible for starting the
largest genocide known to man who is by
his own admission and slaves and beings
to allowed rates who use dismemberment
to control the enslaved who allowed the
killing of infants for sport the truth
is you can't tell elementary kids this
truth and we should not and we should
not be lifting this man up as a hero I
cannot imagine in 200 years a day where
we celebrate Hitler because of some fan
fiction story it's really absurd New
Hampshire should join other states and
municipalities and change in the name of
this day doing so will really hurt no
one keeping it continue with a lie in a
celebration of a man who caused Mass
death and destruction and really
destruction of culture for his own
personal gain not doing so will cause
harm it's an annual reminder for the
descendants of the survivors of genocide
of the ancestors culture story wisdom
and homelands lost this day has caused
harm annually for a very long time
instead we should honor those who have
stored this land for thousands of years
who influenced our governmental
structure that we're participating in
today and whose language we use daily in
our placings it's time to honor those
ancestors that were lost and the bravery
and perseverance of peoples who survived
against all types of Cruelty please vote
in favor of this Bill thank you
thank you for your testimony
um I'm here at delmage I'm impressed
that you pronounced my name correctly
thank you
um I live in Dover New Hampshire
um I'm an Italian-American who doesn't
find pride in Columbus and I'm also a
public school teacher in the state of
New Hampshire and have been for nine
years
um my main reason that I wanted to speak
to you today is that I wanted to share
some of the thoughts of my fifth grade
students um
they studied the quote-unquote discovery
of America and they also discovered
studied the history of the way that
Native Americans have been treated
throughout the history of the United
States
um one of our competencies is to take
informed action based on what we want
social studies and they were given the
option to support or refute this bill
nhb155 they met with our Town
Administrator who was a part of the
process of adopting indigenous people's
day in their town to uncover more about
our community's heritage and they also
met with local indigenous people
um who are living in New Hampshire today
a group of my students decided to
circulate a petition in support of this
bill and they currently have just under
2 000 signatures and they wanted me to
ask you to please vote Yes on this Bill
thank you for listening
thank you for that information I thank
you for your testimony
foreign
we have someone named Maria who wants to
testify
could I just ask Madam chair where was
I don't know she mentioned that the town
adopted indigenous people say so it
might be Exeter
[Music]
The Madam chair I'll also point out that
the Maria is actually state
representative Maria Perez it's not
listed on her name for some reason yes
well I um
I had known that I would have called her
earlier
representative Perez yes thank you for
the opportunity
um yes um my name is Maria Perez I'm a
state representative of District 23 and
then I'm calling to support this bill
it's a Latina from uh Central America
I I don't celebrate Columbus Day and I
don't believe that we should be
celebrating Columbus Day he did such a
trick like horrible thanks to our
communities and Indigent communities and
our countries that I don't believe the
US should be celebrating such a horrible
person I believe we should encourage
people to celebrate Indigent people
um we have so many so many people they
indigen in my country that they should
be celebrated but we don't do that and
then I believe the U.S should be taken
Columbus Day and celebrate it it's an
Indigent day thank you so much for the
opportunity to speak
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
ah okay
the Sierra Club
um my name is is Catherine corkery I'm
the chapter chair for New Hampshire
Sierra Club
we're an environmental group uh with uh
2000 or I'm sorry 20 000 members and
supporters in New Hampshire and we
support the passage of HB 155 indigenous
people's day
uh the indigenous people's day is a way
to
to make up our relations with indigenous
peoples in North America in in New
Hampshire
uh a lot of the testimony we heard today
um kind of talked about indigenous
people who lived in the past
but and and
what I think we are failing to recognize
is that the celebration of
Columbus Day harms people today and and
Indigenous folks today
and unlike St Patrick's Day which is a
saint
uh and not a national holiday
um Columbus Day is is excludes
um people and
it it is ex it celebrates the colonizer
and it celebrates
Columbus specifically who's who's
depravity is recorded by himself
uh as well as other people who saw it
firsthand
um it he was so barbaric
that Columbus's leadership uh was his
own cause uh for his dismissal and
imprisonment when he returned to Spain
on his third trip
um Columbus
um
making the connection that Columbus
represents Italian people
um
I think is is
um it fails to recognize that Italian
people don't celebrate him
um and that there are certainly many
other people of Italian Heritage uh to
celebrate
um but
and and
this bill is a way to correct history
um and to recognize the people who have
survived after generations of abuse and
who are still experiencing that abuse
this this is a way to correct history
that we knew
um and and to see it with clear eyes
um
and not to glorify a man's inhumanity
um but to glorify people and to
celebrate people every all of the
indigenous people
um and and this because there is a
holiday now and we want to re-name a
holiday
um is a way to fix it
and and a record to recognize the harm
and and to see the people
um that we we want to be and to
celebrate
um the holiday of of people and
um there is it as a as another person of
Italian
Heritage I'm a descendant of Italian
Americans too and
um I do recognize that
my ancestors
um had faced discrimination
uh and faced hardships
um for being Catholic and for speaking
different languages and looking
different
but
the
descendants of Italians today do not
face those same hardships
and
by contrast the Ser the folks who
survived Chris Christopher Columbus's
genocide
and and the many people of this
hemisphere who are here today who are
the original
they are still enduring that
discrimination
in a way it and and I I would
respectfully suggest
that this bill
would Grant the relief that my ancestors
searched for
and it would Grant it to folks who are
enduring bigotry and hate today
and I think it would be an honor to
Grant a national holiday to those who
were first Wrong by colonists
and to recognize that indigenous people
can have can use this important tool on
national holiday to lift their stories
and history and culture and practices
and wisdom
for all of us in our country
to recognize
um and I I just want to in an effort to
recognize repair and heal the wounds of
the past New Hampshire Sierra Club
supports changing Columbus Day to
indigenous people's day any other
measure it will not meet that goal and
we asked the committee to support
passage as introduced thank you
thank you for your testimony I'd like to
mention that changing a national holiday
is beyond our power I understand
so
um
[Music]
could you give us your name again please
cheap
[Music]
science
hello
we wanted to know your name
so for the record please no I'm sorry
yes uh Catherine corkery Catherine with
the c
I'm one of the lucky folks who are
Italian and Irish
thank you very much
hello can you guys hear me yes thank you
please introduce yourself and the
testimony
oh yes my name is Sebastian Fuentes I'm
a resident in Thornton New Hampshire uh
initially didn't sign up to testify
but I have a nine-year-old and a
six-year-old sitting here with me
wondering why or not we celebrating
indigenous industry uh people's day
instead of Columbus they're listening
with me the testimony
and I hope I hope you guys support
Israel
I also have the privilege to live in the
North Country New Hampshire
you know I get to enjoy swimming
in the uh
tell me iwase River I get to hike the
one big trails
I work next to the Amazon River
so
this is this is who we are this is the
this is this is what our Community
Values so really quick I'm just here to
please ask you to support this bill
this is not only
gonna bring back and highlight
the real Heritage of me of the country
I'm not a descendant of any Native
American Thrive but I am a descendant of
a South American Thrift the machika
tribe my dad was the first
generation South American Native
so please support HP 155 I appreciate
your time thank you so much
Zach
Zach you should okay yes I think I'm
unmuted now this is uh Zachary Harmon
can you hear me yes okay thank you uh my
name is Zachary Harmon I live in
Goffstown I am an Episcopal priest I
serve in Hampstead but I'm also on the
Reconciliation Commission for the
Episcopal Church of New Hampshire and uh
I want to speak on behalf of that
commission and also with myself
um but wearing the commission hat as the
Episcopal priest you know we believe
that indigenous people and their history
and culture need to be emphasized and
that glorifying atrocities committed by
Columbus should not be done and you know
and some of that was done in the name of
God and kind of from the religious
perspective that that's not something we
want associated with with a God who we
believe is love
um and believe that there is a lot that
is beautiful and amazing about
indigenous culture so many of the place
names in New Hampshire come from the
Abenaki uh language and there's a rich
history to celebrate there and that
there's a lot to really learn uh and uh
personally I I grew up in Alaska uh with
a lot of friends who are indigenous
there and there's just a great amount of
wisdom to learn from indigenous people
it's a rich culture or cultures many
cultures uh and personally though I grew
up in Alaska I was born in the Northeast
and my my family participated in
massacring indigenous people in New
England and was rewarded for it um the
the town of Amherst New Hampshire uh the
one of the first Harmons uh was awarded
uh land there for participating in
massacring native people in Southern New
England uh and it's a it's a dark part
of our history that we need to
reconsider and celebrating Columbus and
celebrating it like other uh speakers
have said and just making it like it's
something to celebrate and look
positively on and not account for these
other things is as uh difficult
I'm also irish-american and uh you know
uh St Patrick's Day isn't a a state
holiday with people getting it off in
the same way and and I you know why why
would the Italian Americans get
something uh that the the Irish do not
you know it's kind of a a strange
question there and uh from the Irish
perspective my family experienced the
famine on another wing of it and if we
were celebrating people who contributed
to the famine my family wouldn't be
happy with that uh and so why are we uh
lifting up somebody who who like
Columbus who did a number of horrendous
things as we've heard about today thank
you very much
thank you for your testimony
what questions is there anyone else who
okay seeing now I'm going to close the
public hearing
the committee is through for the day
we will be together on Friday to exec
's House Bill 499 and house bill 211.
let me thank you for your hard work